I thought, hello, hello, hello everyone.
Retro turkey for retro star.
I'm so fucked up.
I have not set up, okay?
You said, I was like, oh my gosh, it'll be so clever.
That retro turkey for the retro store.
but guys there's one thing missing i i don't have how i act
it doesn't actually feel how i feel in the inside so we
might have to swap skin suits because she looks i look so
happy and not well happy is not really the right word but
she looks so whimsical and so smug but in the inside it's a
dark hole inside i'm so tired i'm so tired there's no
there's no light inside me there's no light but it doesn't
look like it i but there's no light there's no it's just a
dark hole it's just a dark abyss right Oh my god, a swap
skin suits pissing me out.
Oh, I'm so dead inside, right?
I'm so tired.
Oh, there was a mistake.
Why did I put the 1230 stream?
I was 1230 stream after an eight hour Overwatch rank
session.
Oh my god, why did I do that to myself?
Oh, okay, I need it.
We'll still be retro, just not this retro.
It doesn't have the required necessities.
Give me a sec.
I just wanted to show it to you.
Just so I could say I did the joke, you know, just so I
could say, I did know.
I did do it.
The retro, retro joke.
You know, I did do it.
All right, let me see.
Where is it?
Where the fuck is it?
I'm so tired.
I'm like, where is it?
Where did I put it?
Oh, not that.
Where is it?
Boom.
all right give me a sec guys let me come so i'm i'm i woke
up at 12 and then i was i was in the bed and i was like i
can't do this i i was like to myself i can't i can't do this
i'm so tired actually i can't do this
for real it's not it was not okay it was not okay
i got it i got it here we go now this is how i actually feel
i need this on the other skin side me every but you still
went and And I was just like, I was just like, my bed, it's
so comfy.
It's so, it's so, no, it's more like, I, I forgot, like, I,
I did, in hindsight, I forgot that, I forgot that how long I
could play Overwatch for, and then, you know, when you're
playing Overwatch, you're like, yeah, yippee, yeah.
Yay!
Oh, I feel so loud!
And then post-overwatch, you know, the post-overwatch got
me.
And the crash comes in.
Oh, yeah.
And then, yeah.
The pylons, so keep thinking about the pylons.
And then, and I got, I went to bed at, okay, I did go to bed
at May before in the morning, so, but I was doing work,
okay, I was doing behind the scenes, I have a good, a good
excuse at us doing behind the scenes work, so I have a good
excuse, guys, I really do, I really do.
And I got up and I was like, I can't, I can't, I don't think
I can make it at 1230.
I was still in bed and I was just like, I don't want to get
up.
I can't do this again.
That's like next to my manager.
I was like, can you push my stream 30 minutes?
And then, and then at 12, and I didn't get a reply.
And I was like, is he playing deadlock right now?
And then at 1250, he messaged back.
do that i'm in a dead lucky right okay also i got out of my
bed i got i got out of my bed at 12 50.
i was like you know how it's like at 12 20 i was like guys i
need to brush my teeth and like wake up and then obviously
we all assumed that i would have got out of my bed by that
but no i still in that bed i stayed in that bed till 12 50
and I was just like, you could do this.
And I started brushing my teeth at 12, because I looked at
the time at 12.52.
And I'm here now.
I'm here.
Oh, my God.
I'm here for my 9 to 5.
I found out today in Japan.
I don't know why in Japan I found this out.
I just think I Googled it.
I was like, what does 9 to 5 means?
mean it starts at nine and ends at five it means something
else i was like nine to five doesn't mean starting at nine a
.m and and and then like clocking out at five it means like
it's like what was it it's nine hours a day five yeah nine
hours a day five days a week so i'm I'm ready to work at
blockbusters, guys.
I'm back.
I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm in, I'm back to, I'm going to
my, I'm sorry, I can't even construct additional sentences.
All right.
I'm ready to go to my minimum wage job at blockbusters,
clocking it to my nine to five and I cannot construct
additional sentences.
All right.
Here we go.
Where's my game?
Okay, here we go.
I need to save this for the Overwatch sound settings for the
future.
All right.
Let me save this.
Here we go.
I'm ready.
I'm ready for my non-none.
the five uh overwatch there you go not not overwatch i'm
just i was just oh no wait my oh no i froze youtube studios
crashed even even they they're like i'm not ready i became a
png let's let go in my steam crash after i boot up beat
cotton the retro i did it did it did oh oh yep yep it did
crash oh it's gone now it's gone it's it's not it's gone now
goodbye it's not no longer work so close the program cancel
all right give me a sec it's coming back up all right it's
coming back up oh there it's going i also boot up the retro
rewind that's weird i don't know why i crashed there even
the game was like i'm not ready for today's stream me too
game me too the game was like i'm so tired don't worry I'm
also tired let's see where is it there you go connect there
we go I'm back now I'm back just wait a little bit I'll be
back soon there we go I'm back back again all right let's
play it's time I've never been I'll let you guys know I've
never been the blockbusters I don't think my parents I don't
know if they were still around or not by the time I was old
enough or if my parents just never trusted blockbusters
because they're like why rent when we can buy the day I
think my parent no my parents mostly use was it VCDs instead
of VHS I think it was like I think Yeah, I know, I just know
I had more VCDs than I do VHS.
All right, Unlimited, that's right.
We renting our films in, uh, in, in Unlimited, in 500 FPS.
VCDs?
Um, it's like DVDs, but cheaper.
yeah it's it's it's just it's just dvds but cheaper you were
rich rich yeah but thank you the super chat thank you thank
you i didn't have a lot of vhs's i had like i i just
remember um i i didn't it's not i did i had vhs's but like
my parent i just think my parents just didn't trust rental
stores, I think.
Oh, unless it's a library.
I would rent my stuff from the library.
But then I would just rent Veggietails.
I would just rent Veggietails at the library.
But it was, I don't remember.
I think it was, I don't remember it was a VHS or like VCDs.
But we did have a VHS player.
It's just that they just mostly used VCDs instead of VHSs.
And the only VHS tapes I had, I think, I had like a few that
my parents bought for me, where like, one was like, um, oh
my god, wait, actually, I don't remember.
I don't like, one was a Disney film.
That's all I remember.
And then one was some, I just remember one was like, oh my
gosh, it's been so long.
I actually don't remember.
Holy, I know one was a Disney film.
And then the other was like, was like I'm trying it was like
a kids show but I don't remember what kids show it is one
was Disney and the other was kids show I think one was the
original Aladdin movie or some shit and then the other one
was like it was some kids show I'm trying was it blues clues
it could have been blues clues it could it could have been
but then all the other stuff was just VSDs they're like
cheaper than DVDs and they're like you have to have like
multiple discs uh to play to play the whole show or the
movie or some shit simple minded thank you thank you thank
you can you name the store sloppy vids because since it's
you it's you playing we're gonna end up there anyway simple
thank you with a super chat thank you thank you that's all i
can remember regarding like my history of vhs's and oh and i
had one vhs tape where my parents recorded like a bunch of
show like kids shows for me and all i can remember was felix
the cat that's all it could be just it was one episode of
like the ad like not the black and white i'm not like like
150 or some shit but it was like the animated felix the cat
show and with color with color by the way and i all i could
remember was felix the cat and one episode of That's all I
could, that's all I could remember from that fucking VHS
tape that my parents recorded for me to watch.
And I would rewatch that shit all the time.
And yeah, all I could remember was Felix the Cat in that one
Blues Clues episode.
Like I remember the video games I played when I was younger
more than the VHS tape.
Oh man, thank you, a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Gooms, come on, let's head to Land Party.
Play Halo 2 and Burn up Firelight.
while listening to blinking park and green day all right
let's let's go play the game all right i don't know how the
sound is guys i hope it's not too loud all right be kind
rewind but i've heard all the tales about about blockbusters
and and their late fees and why they went bankrupt because
of it in 1990 the golden age of movie rentals and your dream
is about to become reality also i i think my parents just
make me watch tv we didn't really watch much like dv like
you know vcds or vhs i just watch tv or played video game i
didn't watch a lot of move i mean my parents did bring me to
the austin powers movie when i was way too young for it but
i didn't watch a lot of movies i guess i just watched tv i
don't i don't know i just watched tv it was the et 07044
that's my birthday july 4 0704 uh god thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you uh i remember a lot of ads i
saw as a kid growing up from watching TV.
It's time for a Ford rent with a single part-time job
simulator back in the good old days when you can afford
rent.
Was blockbusters mostly an American thing?
Maybe it was just not popular in Canada.
Maybe like my parents were like, we aren't gonna follow your
ways.
Like, we're gonna we're not gonna rent any VHSs.
We're just gonna watch TV.
Like,
I know they were in Canada.
I just don't know if it was popular in Canada Your first day
is about to begin but the shop needs to little love time to
set up a few shows Buy some movies and decorate your stores
I know they used to be everywhere not in cat not where I
lived though.
I don't I mean to be fair I didn't pay a lot of attention as
a kid.
I maybe they were everywhere.
I just didn't notice it
looking at.
Dango, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, hello.
I got you B.
Let's play Super Mario Bros.
3 after watching the wizard and drink some Kool-Aid and
Niel, unless your chips and end up with regret.
Thank you.
Uh, Lego, I hope they have a situation where you can charge
a late fee, even if they are only five seconds late.
Thank you for the super chat.
Lego.
Thank you.
Oh my God.
The sense is crazy for this game.
yeah maybe i'll put it a little higher all right uh i mean i
think it was super chat thank you thank you all right i can
crouch and run access the catalog in the office oh that's me
i'm help access wait that's not the catalog where's the
catalog that's the popcorn oh there's the to experience
blockbuster though oh there it is as a new it's important
for sure when things are quiet you can carry up to oh my god
it's just like my it's just like sea land the municipal of
Canada please come to my store please I'm so please come
this is all I have I want to be able to
jesus turkey you sound miserable i work for retro rewind
please come to my store i access the catalog that wasn't the
catalog wait was this the catalog
no that's the i'm gonna give me a second it's the morning my
brain doesn't work in the morning right it's in the oh the
back is the office that makes sense actually oh my god store
expansion retro oh there it is all right you order three
shows i wish i got to experience blockbuster seems to be a
wild time back in the day in the back store that's the back
pretty pretty neat very detailed i mean it's a simulator all
right if i press v i can pick it up you can rent games oh my
god like console games or i actually heard can you rent pc
games i was just buying my parents would just buy me pc
games at costco Thank you.
Patiosu, thank you.
Do the super chat.
Thank you.
When was the last time you woke up?
I don't remember.
I could change the colors.
Do I care though?
Alright, whatever.
It's almost symmetrical.
It's...
Oh, I can make it yellow!
Wait, I can actually make it look like blockbuster.
I don't know what blockbuster looks like
Guys, I can make it look like blockbuster I don't know what
blockbuster looks like
This is what I think What I think in my head Blockbuster
looks like Who's let's blew up Warcraft 3 and play Angel
Arena All-Stars They use Super Challenge man, everything you
think And if it's like maybe just Asian Asian's parents just
Just would take take your kids to like PC cafes If like
you're like we don't have the game we you we don't have the
game you won We're gonna go to a PC.
That's what my dad did He was like I want to play this this
game And like Doki we're gonna go to a PC cafe It was this
PC cafe that has like manga too So I get to read manga while
my dad games like But I couldn't read Chinese or Japanese So
I was just look at the pretty pictures I just I would just
read any Yasha or some shit I was reading any Yasha and like
Dora Aemon And then there was all there was this one manga I
read I don't know what was going on I was just getting it
off of the images um where it was like uh where it was like
what was it it was like about this dog that looked really
stupid i don't know jennifer it's this dog that looked
really stupid he was like a really special dog and and and
then like and then gets on all these adventures i wish i
were over the name of that manga because i was i was really
cute um
it was really cute i forgot what it was called order movies
order what's new hollywood new oh and market 10.
oh it's free i like free stuff oh it's no longer free but
there's so many free stuff all right pick up oh is this cool
so you guys don't see the movie but I could carry 10.
Alright, here you go.
I remember renting Yoshi Island Kirby Superstar for the
SNES.
At Corner Stories.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, Lolly.
Nate, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Toki Koen finally arrived.
May bring me luck.
I'm sorely missing while gaming.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
I gotta put it in.
Solid.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Oh, shit.
I'm dropping all.
I don't get paid enough for this.
I just want to.
I just want to buy.
New Halo.
I want to buy Halo.
And then afford a new.
My first car.
So I could take my.
My high school sweetheart.
to prom all right there you go let's let's put the the rest
of this here there i got it save your progress with the time
clock machine clocking into my nine to five a car in this
economy yes It's crazy to think about, but back then, you
can afford a car working at Las Vegas.
What a time to be alive.
You used the employee time clock machine.
Cars were just $2 back then.
And inflate.
for inflation okay here we go there's an auto save feature
at the beginning of each new day
look up at oh wait we could name this store how do i name it
oh there you go
copy i couldn't just name it
Tokey is a blockbuster.
Block.
That's it.
Copy.
It's not cop.
Technically, it's legally distinct blockbuster.
If I remember correctly, Moon Boy, it was around five bucks.
And so here's your pay for the hour.
Thank you.
We're in a super chat.
All right.
Not blockbuster.
Okay.
All right.
Name color.
I want to make it more blue.
There you go.
It's slightly more blue so you can tell it's not
blockbuster.
It's slightly more blue, guys.
there you go not blockbuster legally water tight all right
turn on the open sign i don't get paid enough to short it by
genre it says mixed and it shall be mixed what is that the
sinful red keyboard juice the plant pot in this room the
heart is the fish toy the skeleton knocking oh yeah some of
the oh hi there sir some of the vcds that i owned that my
sorry not me my parents own was dr slump oh my gosh i love
dr slump here you go give me your money wait
feedback less well how much did he give me oh one dollar
here you go sir oh here you go sir this feels too real this
is yeah it'll be dr slump and then that's all i could
remember because all i did was just watch dr slump on the
bcd i know there were more of oh and what else oh 12 that's
so much there you go sir Hello.
Hello, man.
$1.
That's all I could remember.
Let's just remember that.
I watched so...
I just re-watched so much Dr. Slump, guys.
I love Dr. Slump.
It's, like, one of my favorite shows.
Because I grew up...
I grew up watching it from my mom's VCDs.
Because my mom...
Oh, and...
Modico Chan?
Is that the Japanese name?
I call her Su-Yin-Z.
Biddy-bada, biddy-bada.
Because that was like my mom's VCDs.
Because my mom was a anime.
My mom and dad were both anime fans.
And then I would have VCDs of Maruko-chan and Dr. Slup.
Please come to my store.
I need money.
Are you okay?
I have to work so I can afford a nice prom date for my high
school sweetheart.
She expects those flower thingy.
Wait, what is it?
I don't scare my grandma.
What should we watch?
Sure.
You should watch.
He waits for breakfast.
That looks so scary.
Alright, the fish book.
Here's a dollar, man.
Corsage.
She wants a corsage imported from Europe.
I gotta make my baby happy.
$16?
Alright.
I gotta work card and then if i'm lucky she'll let me hold
her hand i'm like good i'm a i'm a good boyfriend
all right nice oh i'm running out of tapes guys my business
is booming not blockbusters that was neat thank you oh yeah
i already said thank you i already read that i'm losing
track of what i've read that's a good movie sir here's two
dollars also is the sound okay guys i is the sound okay yeah
she wants a limousine for prom and what she wants i get
because I love her.
Is VCD...
Oh yeah, so VCD is really super common back in...
Back in, like, Hong Kong.
But yeah, I just...
Instead of VHSs, that's what my parents had.
Hello, have you decided what you want, sir?
Hello, have you decided what you want?
I had a huge VCD.
collection
what is oh what is it ma'am i come oh sure don't worry i got
you the sinful tentacle oh that'll go great with the ladies
you can be scared and
all right i'm ready ready to rent it for you
50.
Oh, it's 7.
I finished what phrase?
What are you guys talking about?
Please come to my store.
I need to make enough promise in a week.
Promise in a week.
And I, not for me.
Who are you?
Oh, I can't hit them like in the water park again.
Okay.
finish today I don't need to finish today there's money to
be made I sell all of those videos I mean rent all of them
400 yeah but I have to pay rent I still have three more
videos there they all gotta go I'm getting faster guys
okay that stuff toy is this just all horror films wait maybe
i can i can have one more person oh no it's so scary at
night oh i don't know if i like that i gotta close the door
wow a hundred dollars in inflation that would have been like
five hundred dollar Oh, I got a new shelf.
Yay, another day at not Blockbuster.
Let's go.
Calendar.
What's on the calendar?
Every morning affects gameplay exciting ways when you
release a special events, a task list for various
objectives.
It is also available.
Oh, shit.
I get, there's a new movie to order it.
Oh my god, business is...
First day I complete it.
I can sell popcorn?
Okay.
I gotta grab Meteor Shout.
Okay, wait.
I gotta...
Nothing for today.
Tape dealer Tuesday and Thursday?
What day is today?
It's Monday.
Oh my god.
oh yeah stab oh i can get i can hire more minimum wage
workers to have a group what the fuck that's my sweetheart
right there every time i pee i can look at it
you gotta be able to have i gotta be able to hire more
minimum wage workers to enjoy a wonderful day working at not
blockbusters i love i love it here
i'm so happy all right so they can be rented out again you
can return and hold how many people have returned oh okay oh
nice oh my god people are actually returning
Be kind rewind chat Be kind rewind Sorry, I think I hated
Rewinding these the most
The reserve slot Who the fuck reserved this?
We have so many copies of these That's right It's five
dollars per day That's our late fee Okay If you don't like
it, go to blockbusters.
Oh, Doreen and he left.
That's right.
We all, we have, we're all that's left.
Oh.
All right, put that in.
All right.
Whoops.
Yeah.
We got more videos now.
We are open.
Where's your clock in?
Wait, that's where I save.
There it is.
That's right.
We're the only rental company.
I know, what would you like?
I got you, girl.
Here you go.
I wish I can, like, charge more.
you're blocking the line.
Ma'am, you're blocked.
Ma'am, please, you're blocking the line.
Alright.
That's all you want.
Here's one dollar.
I need to start by category.
The category is all a horror.
I have nothing else.
That's the only... I don't even have to figure it out.
I just No, it's all horror.
What do you mean?
This is, oh, it's drama.
What?
The angry tomb is drama?
The...
Nevermind.
Plus drama.
But...
I have one movie that is not horror.
That's crazy.
I didn't get paid enough to sort by category.
It says, oh, wait.
I do...
It does say it.
Alright, let's see.
What?
Or do I?
You know what?
When the store is dead, I'll sort by category.
Let's see.
Oh.
Alright, I'll do it now.
Alright, here you go.
Let's see.
Horror...
Oh, shit.
Who's calling me?
I'm trying to sort by category.
basement cassette torture sure all right there you go
and then this is drama look at that i'm so good at this sure
grab this it's called a plant for pot plants pot in his room
there you go this is horror
now look at that I should buy more films I think I can
afford it honestly hello what you like sir oh yeah I have it
here you go sir there's the film you rent wanted to rent two
dollars all right you know what I think I can afford more
movies let's see buy random $60 wait I can buy individual
movies which one do I not have the comedian in Tim's room oh
that has a lot of good ratings new movie new movie added
it's from Tim Burton himself more horror you're right guys
we should more horror films.
It's just all oops, all horror whoops, all horror.
All horror.
There we go.
That could win an Oscar.
Wait, this one.
I literally just bought it.
46.
Why do you carry 50?
Oh my, okay, it's fine.
damn we got the big bills i have one movie left that's all
you can rent
do it all right there you go
all right guys i'm having my second win i'm waking up now or
i'm i'm feeling it now i'm feeling i'm feeling the passion
I'm feeling the passion right now.
All right.
Okay, it might be...
Wait, are you the...
Oh, you reserved a cop.
There you go.
There you are.
All right, don't worry.
I got some more movies coming in.
Coming in hot.
Four more horror films.
There you go.
No, no, no.
They're not empty.
There they are.
Coming in hot.
Let's see.
You know what?
More horror!
They're just all horror!
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
I think I have a good variety of films, chat.
Alright.
I'm tired of horror crowds.
That's too damn bad!
We're a horror company!
That's where we get the money.
Oh, oh, shit.
Don't take my $5, please.
You know what?
I can order more horror.
Oh my god.
We have more horror.
Let's go.
We're in the horror business.
That's what sells.
I hope he's not looking for anything.
An old movie.
What's old?
this looks old is this old no they're just on horror I don't
know what's old this goes old this goes not old I can
inspect it oh this is old there you go don't keep these
all right
it says old when you hover no it doesn't it just says horror
oh there it does it does say old all right
here you go I need to use the bathroom can you wait a bit
I'll be right back I'll be in the back room using the
bathroom sir out the true experience he's not gonna walk
away i'm the only rental store in the in the town
is this guy still here okay all right let's go that must be
a good-ass movie that you want all right here you go sir he
is actually still here damn uh it's not real as That movie
was that good.
He's just like, God, he's gotta get his films, guys.
His wife's gonna be very mad if he doesn't get that film for
movie net.
Let's grab the mixed bag.
I have enough money.
Is that more horror?
You know what?
Fuck this drama shit.
Get that shit out of here.
Get that.
It's a horror only store.
Alright, nice.
Now we're cooking.
Um Yoko, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
I would like to rent a horror movie.
The one where the hot ghost girl comes up from your TV.
Do you have it?
Oh yes, yes.
It's seven days to die.
The ring.
Yes, yes.
Of course we do.
We have 20 copies of it.
I think we need 10.
I think we need 20 more though.
The ring will never die.
Yoko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
WB, Maddie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do you think like, do you think the Gen Alpha knows what the
Ring Girl is?
Like, I feel like the Ring Girl and Grudge is like retro
now, isn't it?
Do you think about it?
It came out like, what, 20 plus years ago?
Makes me wonder if they know what they are.
Akata!
Slushy machines!
Or a new least this movie will concern you make it extremely
popular oh shit can i have like make an open now while i do
that just grab to get the customers now uh buy at least five
all new releases have a custom sandy included when five
copies buy at least five i'll buy more than five i'll buy 20
I'm going all in I didn't even see what movie this is on
poetry is dead
that's right all in oh husband we're homeless now because
you spent all your money on poetry is dead I'll do it again
Alright, here we go It's all drama Where the fuck's my
standy?
Oh, there it is We are Poetry is dead in horror Company now
There we go
Oh, fuck that, that's not poetry is dead Every Tuesday if
you're after exclusive okay wait at 9 p.m don't worry i can
make this all back one dollar oh here you go sir oh yes i do
do i have a new release for you
okay Thumb commenters return here.
Oh, that's right.
Our late, we do have late fees.
Damn right we do.
Guys, I'm running out of shell spaces.
Where can I put, that's not poetry is dead.
I'm putting that on the floor.
That,
only poetry is dead on my shelves.
Hello.
Sir, I need Poetry is dead.
Let's go.
And it's $3 per rental.
Need another horror show?
You're crazy.
How dare you say that?
My shelves are only for poetry.
That seems like reckless spending, guys.
Reserve.
Alright.
I just put it on the floor like this.
Does it have to be, like?
Alright.
I'll put it on the floor.
$4.
Yay!
Alright, we gotta grab all of these.
Oh, late.
Nice.
Get them.
Get them with the late fees.
That's looking right.
If you have, like, you can...
Couldn't you just technically, like, rent a movie?
like a movie that you really really want and then never
return like never come back to the store because then you
can't technically you can't pay a late fee if you're i want
a old horror film oh shit okay give me a sec oh there you go
i got one is that possible you just let okay five dollars
like all you have to do is just never come back to the store
And you can...
Oh, they send you a letter?
Or if...
A fucking VHS tape fucking Blockbuster will take my credit?
Who would ever do that?
That's how it works?
Imagine if you lose all your credit because you forgot you
rented, like, some fucking...
Some fucking Aladdin movie for your kid.
Like, sorry, kid.
Daddy has no credit no more Because I rented Aladdin and
then I forgot where I put it
Should have paid that late fee
But Or there's already An item on the Oh my god there's so
many returning Movies why can't they all be late Like
regular Like normal people How am I gonna take advantage of
them if they They all returned their movies in a timely
manner.
I hope going all in on poetry is dead is not a bad...
Was not the worst mistake of my business.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, rewind.
Be kind rewind.
Oh, oops.
Oh, shit.
I keep it accidentally.
My hands are like jello.
Hello, ma'am.
You want a horror movie?
An old movie would be better.
Alright, let's see.
Old, old.
Old!
There you go.
Wow.
Oh.
That's right.
They are necessary.
That's what...
Oh, my God.
That's how I get you.
That's right.
Make you forget it, bud.
Like, like, those gym memberships hello oh you here you go
that's how i'm gonna get you god damn capitalism
uh is that not 35 oh 50.
do you think they actually pick it off the floor do i need
shows for these or it's fine i'll just restock it here we'll
have eventually find a film that they won oh it's my it's my
dealer my tv not not that my dvd dealer guys my
it's my dvd dealer oh my god poetry is dead it's it's going
off the shelves
my bhs and dvd dealer you guys want to see him the first
one's free see he's in the back alley oh shit i got bootleg
movies for half their market value exclusive adult titles
and the occasional good stuff oh shit it's got the good shit
does he have horror he has horror oh my god the adult oh my
god let's get out of the adult movie the two horrors and
then another the plumber in his body part now we'll leave
that one for later we'll leave all right so we have oh wait
we need a shelf up section all right shelves six rows wait
what's the difference between standard oh i guess that holds
more wait can i afford all right i can afford i can afford
this all right that's fine i don't think i need to pay
electricity bills like i'm not sure but like it feels like i
don't have to pay bills the adult section can go right here
so i know what you are i so i know what you are and then
more oh i don't have enough room for horror i'll just put it
on the ground um yeah i need a curtain that's true how much
did i lose $41 runies.
Let's go.
My brother went to Link to the Past from Blockbuster.
Kept it for three to four months before we found out.
We never returned.
See?
You never see?
Dangl was okay.
His credit, I assume your credit was okay, right?
Dangl.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uncle, thank you for the super chat.
Fun retail story.
One time I had to tire the vents my junk against... So,
okay.
I don't know why, but he's very intent on grabbing it.
the super chat thank you thank you see i bet your credit was
okay okay maybe not oh maybe okay was not the right word
it's time to take your and prove your job your shop sorry
your shop with decorations snack displays arcade machines uh
and other goodies to draw in more customers keep an eye out
for special events unlock new movie genres hire staff expand
your store and discover plenty of surprises along the way i
like surprises now you may need to actually sort that's how
i got an awkward video instead of the mummy ones thank you
the super chat thing oh i would put like vhs tapes on where
i'm uh on not movies well you know like same with games i
would not put the tapes on the right gate like on the right
boxes all right time to be kind rewind oh my god it's all
i told you it would fly off the shelves guys i told you it's
just off it's off poetry oh and then the occasional horror
uh don't worry i got you i got poetry is dead
oh my god the hologram let's put that in the front it's
flying it's flying off the shelves guys what would you do
with 20 copies it's a classic you'll never die
area male pick oh somebody went whoa he's having a good time
and poetry is dead to make it more classy you know
i wonder what stops blockbusters from not Okay, I guess like
it's legal But wouldn't couldn't you just like Rent a movie
from blockbuster and then like copy the movie
Like can't be like what's stopping you from then you'll
never have to and then you have your own movie collection
Shit Doki you wouldn't download a car would you I would like
why people who ask that's like a fucking course Of course I
download a car.
That's just...
An old movie.
Do I have an old movie in this pile?
Oh, there you go.
Who would ever say no?
Exactly.
Why would you say no to that?
The car's there.
Just rent...
Mr. Broken Bond.
Leave the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Unlimited Act.
Just...
Wait, that's not...
Oh, that is horror.
Alright, I still have more horrors.
I think I bought too many horror films?
Nah.
It's a classic.
Oh, late.
Nice.
And then we'll put that here.
And then one more.
Um...
With the cask under the bridge.
Alright, what do you want?
You want a horror film?
I got you.
Watch.
Bam!
Here you go.
Ooh, a holographic.
Limited edition.
It's only the cover that's holographic for sure.
Just a box.
Or is it Disney's section?
This not blockbuster is not for kids.
Go to blockbuster if you want Disney.
We got Disney films.
We have three categories only.
Horror, adult, and poetry is dead.
It's its own category.
Just...
All right, Tim.
All right, here you go, Tim.
my daughter only watches then it's time for her to grow up
and then would anyone like to come to my store oh ma'am i
know you just oh you were just here oh it's planning to stop
by oh my god they are all braving the waters for me all
right oh shit all right let me hello hello I work and your
store hours make it almost impossible I wanted to voice my
it will not happen again what do you mean wait I can be open
up later wait why can't I legally technically operate later
I guess like I mean if i'm the owner i can make my own hours
right oh wait i should put more horror on the on the shelves
they're like flying off right now oh shit sorry ma'am sorry
wait what if i put this in your basket
hey drama movie there you go i guess i can put more oh my
god i ran out of poetry is dead.
Back in She actually filled this shelf with drama now.
That's crazy.
I told you guys.
I told you my investment in poetry is in 20 copies of poetry
that's dead would work out.
I told you.
My 20 copies.
I actually actually red.
I actually have more shelf space now.
I don't think it's working.
Oh my gosh, she won so many movies.
You didn't believe!
Oh my gosh, so many customers.
I can work even later.
Alright.
More horror?
Don't mind if I do.
Don't worry, let me put this here.
And then...
Ma'am, come to my store.
Come to my store, please.
Not blockbuster.
Come to my store.
Oh, shit.
Bunka, ring, ring, ring.
Alright, movie must only rewind.
It's not big deal, but please...
What?
How dare you say that?
I rewind all my videos.
I can't believe you could say such lies about my store.
I have a machine that does the work for me.
Or imply my machine did a bad job.
Alright, be kind, rewind.
Oh.
There we go.
I'm getting better at the cash register thing.
all right one dollar there you go all right i think we made
it we had a good day let's look at the calendar okay we need
more 80 oh i need chocolate bars equipment how do i get
chocolate bars decoration door mat okay we don't need that
oh slushy machine all right we repair it oh my god we got
the slushy oh my guys my tomagachi he's definitely not gonna
live i'm never good with it how do i do this and then
got a slushy oh hey how do i how do i clean this oh oh oh
Wait.
If I just step on it, I'll clean itself.
Oh, it cleans by time.
Oh, there you go.
See, it's disappearing, guys.
I did it.
I cleaned it.
It's okay.
The floor ain't my slushy.
That's something future Joki can worry about.
Sci-fi!
I didn't like sci-fi!
all right now i'm to time to make sure i'm to look at all my
poetry is dead oh what's that poetry is dead oh be kindly
one there you go
all right look at that poetry is dead all right get out of
here you're not poetry is dead all right oh and the adult oh
my gosh they're already done they won and done that oh
reserved they reserved one day they were so scared they're
like oh no
all right and then we'll put this right here my good old
adult films and then my horror
Oh, reserve.
All right, there you go.
We're open for business.
I wonder if I can...
Is there more of a...
Okay.
Science fiction.
Oh, who's calling me about...
At home, I don't watch...
Do you take donations?
Oh, yes.
Please.
I would love some donations, please.
Is it Poetry is dead?
Oh, it's horror and drama.
I mean, that's fine.
It's not...
Poetry is dead, but that's fine.
We only, if you're going to donate, we only take one film
and one film only.
Oh, wait, there's a black...
Oh!
Order Pirate Movie.
Wait, how do I...
I need to find Poetry is dead.
Oh!
You have it?
Oh my god.
Good talk, good thing.
The thing I got, the movie you've been looking for.
Alright, let me grab some pamphlets.
Please come to my store.
Please.
Oh, I'm to write.
Poetry is dead.
Blue Sinroy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is that poetry is dead?
I got that.
I got 20 copies of that.
Alright, 250.
See, why did they reserve?
It's flying off the shelves.
Of course they'll reserve it.
They gotta make sure they get a copy before it's too late.
Do you want a slushie?
Why does no one want a slushie?
That poetry is dead.
Ooh.
I hope you have a good night tonight, girl.
This is the smallest bill I have.
Might as well just fucking buy the tape.
Alright, oh, and poetry is dead.
Good choice, good choice.
Oh.
Oh, you're here to reserve.
Don't worry, I got you.
Poetry is dead.
Oh.
Oh, she wants this post.
think specifically this version.
Oh.
All right.
Okay, let's see.
How would they...
How come no one wants my slushie?
What if I just make a slushie for them?
Grape slushie.
Would you like a grape slushie, sir?
Would you like a slushie, sir?
Wait.
Would you like a slushie?
Alright.
Good choice.
Poetry is dead.
Really good choice, sir.
Very good choice.
Honestly, one of the best movies out there.
Oh, you were, sir.
Poetry is dead?
Oh, great choice, ma'am.
Great choice.
Oh, and another one.
Oh, and you want a slushie?
Oh, fuck yeah, let's go.
Here's your slushie, ma'am.
More slushies for us.
That's true.
More slushies for me.
Alright.
Oh, exact change.
I like what I see.
My god.
Only three copies left.
The poetry is dead.
Wait a minute.
I'll put this here.
And then this here.
Oh.
And then.
This.
Here.
So that I can put the other.
Dramas.
In here.
Whoops.
my hands they're like jelly and it's all oops all horror and
then i'll put it here and then one horror here and then the
last poetry is dead
hello sir
give me a science fiction oh okay uh old science fiction
Ooh, can I interest you in...
Oh, it's free.
Wait, I have a free science fiction.
Are any of them old?
Oh, these, this one's old.
Sir.
Sir, lucky for you.
I have what you're looking for.
And it was free.
Oh, I have a science fiction section now.
for my science fiction shelf.
There you go.
Now it's just, this is now a sci-fi shelf now.
Whatever works.
$3.
Hey, it was free, guys.
I didn't have to pay for it.
What do they do actually pick it off the floor?
You think they'll pick it off the floor if I just leave it
there?
I'm ready to test that theory out.
Oh, and a blueberry slushy?
Don't worry, ma'am.
I'll grab you that blueberry slushy.
No?
Well, that means they have to take what they can get on the
shelves.
Oh, 46?
There you go.
I'm sure if they have no standards.
Holy shit!
$100?
That's like a million if you count for inflation.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
It's the It's my dealer.
Oh my god.
You were waiting.
You've been waiting for it.
I got the movie for you.
Poetry is dead.
See you guys?
I told you.
You should get more shelves.
You're fucking crazy.
man two copies of poetry is dead holy shit he's gonna have
like each room is gonna play poetry is dead an old movie all
right let's see there you go here you go put your hands in
here and give me art this is a robbery also high sleepy head
black phone thank you thank you thank you Alright, I'm here
for the adult movies.
Oh, the double swirl tape.
My chimp her desire.
Do not the monkey.
Ooh.
Nah, we don't need that.
I got my adult shelf here.
That's right.
In the corner.
The tough part is when Doki takes Looney's after Dan has to
convert it off to Looney's.
Tunis.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, the last day.
Oh my god.
See, guys, I bought 20 copies of Poetry is Dead.
I come end the day with five copies.
Look at that.
I told you.
It'll fly off the shelves like crazy.
I knew everyone called me crazy for buying $300 of copies of
is dead but look who's laughing now look at that prophet
i've been waiting for the release oh my gosh four copies of
poetry is dead
oh and an adult all right which movie are you getting sir oh
oh oh i'm sorry for watching oh
You got...
My bad, sir.
My bad.
I should have let you shop in peace.
I was curious.
I wanted to know which copy was gonna get.
All right.
Drama, movies.
Oh, you know what is drama?
Poetry is dead.
Poetry.
Yeah.
all right just have a promo of poetry plus i'm talking all
right that's not poetry is dead when is this bullshit
all right rewind put that out of here i need to restock my
shelves for the good shit Oh, reserved?
Oh, poetry is dead.
Of course, that's reserved.
That shit out of here.
There's a sci- it's sci-fi time.
No, sorry.
It's not.
It's drama time.
Alright, we gotta get these out of here first before.
And then it's all poetry is dead.
Alright.
Alright, poetry is dead.
And then today's sci-fi day.
Or sorry, now today's drama day.
And poetry is dead.
Poetry is dead.
And then horror.
Where did that come from?
Yeah, when are we getting the sequel?
The poetry is dead.
Poetry is definitely dead.
The sequel.
Alright, poetry is dead.
Dead.
Poetry is dead.
Oh, reserved.
Yeah, I would reserve that, too.
Poetry lives.
Poetry is dead, too.
Oh, shit.
My hands are full.
No longer.
Why do I even walk out?
I could just throw it from here.
Oh, shit.
The adult movies came back.
I mean, it is a one and done thing.
I feel like there's no rewatch ability.
I feel like there's no rewatch ability for this.
Hello?
Sorry, wrong number.
Night of the...
Alright, we are open!
Come in!
Come to my store.
Give me watch out.
You were standing there.
Please come to my store.
Come to my store, please.
Oh, you're gonna come to my store regardless?
Oh, is that like a wallet or some shit?
Oh, you're gonna come to my store?
There you go.
Oh, it's the pamphlets I gave him.
Hello, are you...
Oh, I'm here to pick up the movie poetry is dead.
There you are, girl.
There you are.
Oh my god, it's flying off the shelves, guys.
It really is.
Too bad it's the only option, but it really...
Oh, oh, you're not here for the drama.
You're here for the spice.
My man.
Alright.
There you go.
Everything else is on the floor because everything else
doesn't matter we're
here to push one thing and one thing only horror and poetry
is dead i'm all in
stop and then after but then the third and then the second
sequel is stop poetry is already dead oh put it here and
then we'll put the other drama films on here there you go
now now you can have the other drama films it's gonna pose
gonna burst no it's gonna live forever not the poetry part
though
it's it's gonna become a classic and then it's gonna win an
Oscar and then you're gonna feels so silly.
It's gonna win an Oscar and then I can put a tape on, like
the sticker on it, it's like, uh, Oscar nominated film.
You're gonna feel so silly.
Oh my I got two adult films.
Oh, and sunglasses in the store.
I know what you are.
Poacher's Dead 30th Expedition 33.
It It's good.
It's no!
It had good reviews!
Do I have a new... Oh, do I have a new release for you?
He's very confident for round two.
Have more...
Oh, I could buy more potion.
Yes, I could buy more!
buy another 20 just in case you're so right i understand why
is my horror not selling well oh jk oh you're so oh my god
he's here to pick up i knew it
i don't need more shells i have all i need all i need dead
will never die.
Viva la poetry.
Bozzy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't need more shows.
I have all the shows I need.
If...
Hello, everyone.
Oh, I've been waiting for it.
Don't worry.
I got you, sir.
We are the only store that carries all... Oh, is it possible
to reserve poetry?
Never punished.
Look at that.
never fucking punished oh yeah two dollars that should be
twenty dollars I'll go to another oh good luck good luck
girl we're the only video store in five counties should have
paid should have supported your local businesses ma'am wait
which one blueberry oh shit okay does that mean i can reuse
oh wait i don't think they wanted rainbow i think i fucked
it up
what's your go-to adult movie i think i ran out of adult
films wait what's the sku adult oh double swirl tape six
nine all right let's copy that oh my god what here this is
my recommended
there you go I'll make it back
oh my god I should ran out of drama films that's actually
crazy wait you know what that means don't keep no That's
right, I should order more drama films.
But you know what that?
Guys, I'm running out of copies!
I'm running out!
Oh my gosh, she resisted.
Don't worry.
Oh my gosh, I'm actually running out.
Don't get me stopped.
Guys, but I'm running out, though.
Oh my gosh, she's going to grab me.
Okay, no, she's not grabbing that.
It's time to buy more.
Oh, they're picking up another one.
Oh, he's picking up a copy.
Wait, wait.
He's picking it up.
Oh, wait.
He's not.
No, he's thinking about it.
He left.
Come back.
Come back to the store right now.
Oh, Sheper, I had to give her a backroom.
I was like, why are you still here?
Leave.
Oh, no.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shit.
Oh, it's fireworks.
Yay!
Happy New Year!
Oh, my God.
It's the last copy.
Good choice, sir.
Good choice.
Oh, my good.
You made a...
good choice sir oh wait I gotta wait people are still coming
in you know what that means one more copy
okay watching boring I like enjoy okay drama bad movie shit
drama and it has to be bad drama drama.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, wait.
He wanted bad.
I think he just wanted bad and drama.
There you go.
Got you.
Oh, end up.
Come on.
Pick it up.
What a good way to end.
Oh my god, we know what he never punished, never, no shot,
don't you?
He'll never, he'll never die.
It just worked.
Poetry is dead as forever.
One bad, one bad.
good let's go incredibly custom-made
oh nice i have a snack shelf now all right get this stupid
ass sign fiction out of here
all right grab this out oh it's broken so i'll add some
broken feet.
Oh, nice.
Okay, that's fine.
How do I throw it?
Oh, it's here.
No!
It's alright.
It's just a horror film.
It's not poetry.
It's dead.
It's that drama.
Horror is out.
Drama is in.
Boom.
Alright.
Drama.
Alright, now give me the good shit.
Oh, rewind.
It was one and a put...
No, it wasn't.
Alright.
Oh, rewind.
Sorry, I can put this here.
Got my rewinding.
Whoa.
Alright.
Oh, reserve.
Good choice.
Good choice, ma'am.
Oh, rewind.
Can't wait for the sequel, guys.
Alright.
What the fuck is this?
Why is there a green tape in my drama video store?
This was the best movie that ever come out.
I hope it wins 80 Oscars.
Oh.
Whoa, whoa, okay, all right.
Man, we're gonna have a wild night tonight.
Damn.
She needed that tape reserved.
Oh, no.
I mean, it's just...
No, it's my holographic!
You might as well rip the holographic card.
I'll put...
Put it here, but I don't want to...
want it touching poetry is there you're not staying the same
shelf as them but can i do this when it's not open yet oh
wait i can't all right i think i can buy a snack stand now
bye please
next to the adult counter as it should be as
Much slime.
Let's go.
Dino, gummies, firecrunch.
Oh, it should be...
Oh, shit.
I'm trying to stock up my stack bar.
Gangster temptation?
Do I have that?
Oh, here.
I said yes, so I'll have it by the time he gets here.
I'll have it by the time he's here.
No, no, okay.
I got you.
Here you go.
Alright, I might need another shell.
Alright, let me...
Before we do that, let me look into...
And then we get Disco Con for the...
For the monkey on Dawnfield.
Ooh.
Ooh, it gets wild when it's a cheesy chips.
Hey.
Yeah?
Oh yeah, you sure did.
You want some...
You should grab some chips.
with this later i just stocked it up
and let me put one oh my god i'm it's already almost gone
all right my poetry is dead good choice sir good choice
okay oh and a slushie i might need to hire a worker soon
It's going wild.
It's going being a little too intense now.
Alright, we need to grab...
Wait, what did I want to buy?
Oh yeah, I want to buy another shelf.
Alright, how much do I have?
Alright, new releases, movie shelves.
Six rows.
Oh!
Okay, what?
I can put all...
I can put it all there.
Okay.
all right here you go what do you need i've been waiting for
it don't worry wait this is more expensive that's right you
damaged my movie
that's fucking right that shit was holographic all right
snacks all right cheesy snacks here and then more And then
all fudge slime.
There you go.
Oh my god, the dolphin.
Wait.
With the chips.
My man.
My girl.
You know how to party.
Oh my god.
Poetry is dead.
It's finally.
Alright.
We're here.
Okay.
And then.
Sci-fi.
We finally have sci-fi back on the shows.
I think I invested too much in horror, guys.
It's the me.
Oh, and a slushie?
I'll be fine.
I just need it.
It'll ring for a little bit.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I do.
I do.
I actually, I do still have a copy.
The holographic one.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
I'll just reuse it.
Yep.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
I still have another copy.
All right.
Next customer.
The next obvious salute.
Two copies.
Whoa.
Back the... I mean, I mean, that is smart.
So you don't have to rewind it after you're done watching.
You just put in another copy.
It is, I will say, it's pretty convenient, guys.
Instead of rewinding it, I just put it in another copy.
It goes hard.
Oh, with the fudge slime.
The tactical reload.
Exactly.
Reload cancel.
Alright, 16.
Alright, we're going to go.
We'll put...
Put it all here.
This is new shelf.
Oh, wait.
I gotta paint it.
Um, yellow.
Wait, that's not yellow.
What did I paint?
Oh, materials list.
Okay, that should be blue.
Wait, that's it.
That's all I could paint?
How am I supposed to be not Blockbuster?
Oh, a bad movie.
Here.
Oh, wait, that's old.
Old?
Bad.
There we go.
Oh my, this is like the TCG simulator, but for video it's
for Poetry is dead.
I mean, where else am I supposed to pick it from if not from
the floor?
I mean, I have another shelf just for horror now.
Just for horror, nothing else.
Two shells for horror.
Oh, wait, here.
Here you go.
Thank God you reserved it.
They're flying off the shells right now.
Oh my god, we have two copies left, guys.
I might have to buy another copy.
Wait, is there anyone outside?
Oh.
Please come to my store.
No!
Oh, he's already coming.
Yay!
Happy second new year!
Alright, sci-fi.
Ooh.
A little snack, too.
Double New Year!
New Year's, too!
The sequel!
Oh my god, that's a lot of films he has in there.
Here's your Slushie.
A little poetry.
Oh, yes.
Ready to scan that for you.
Ooh, and some cheesy chips along the way.
Here you go, man.
See, $1.50.
New Year's so good, they started it again in March.
It was good for the economy, okay?
It was really good for the economy.
Oh my god, I could have put chocolate bars.
I forgot about the chocolate bars.
Oh my god, another new movie I have.
Wait, is that even chocolate?
right?
Fudge.
That was the whole point of the snacks, Dad.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh my god, poetry's dead too!
Oh my god, did it come out!
Alright, let's... What's the new movie, guys?
What's the new movie?
It's time to put another order down.
Bad dreams on Mel.
road you know what that means 20 copies all in I can't
believe they went I can't believe they went horror I'm done
playing with you oh my god it was a weird pivot the writers
the writers decided to pivot into horror the writer was like
it was a bad po he got a bad critic review and then he
stabbed him now poetry is undead what the fuck is this
garbage in my hand get that shit out of here no we don't
need more shells we only need we have just enough
what could go wrong that's what they said about poetry is
dead and then look at the money I made there you go you will
never wake up from this
nightmare yeah oh put this here and then drama will be here
get that sci-fi shit out of here.
It's not your day.
That's also a duck.
Now these late fees are...
How long can you usually rent movies for at Blockbusters?
There's a lot of late fees.
A week?
Damn, my store charges a day.
Okay.
as it should teaches them responsibility.
Yeah, watch that movie tonight.
Alright, we'll put the sci-fi on this shelf.
Oh.
Yeah, that's right.
A day!
The Rocket Man tragedy.
Oh my god, just put that down.
Alright, let's see.
That is drama.
That's the things to do.
You should have thought of that before returning that tape
late.
You could have found a friend to return it for you.
Oh my god, my hands are so...
If only I had more hands.
For the critically acclaimed movie, Poetry Is Dead and It's
Sequel.
Bad Dreams on Mel Street.
Oh, wait.
I ran out of hands.
Can't be.
Alright, JK.
Fuck sci-fi.
This is more important.
There we go.
Oh, get this out of here.
Oh.
Alright.
Put that here.
And then put these two here.
And then we're open for business.
Anyway, I'm going to hire another minimum wage worker.
Alright, applicants.
No!
I'm not level 6.
Never mind.
I'm almost there, though.
Come one, come all.
Awesome, I'll come back.
Damn right, you will.
Oh, what are you looking for?
I have the movie.
I hope I'm not too late.
Wait, what?
Oh, here it goes.
Don't worry, sir.
You're never too- Oh, wait, I have more?
What the fuck?
Where did these come from?
Oh.
Put that here.
We'll put these two here.
And there you go.
Alright, I'll do these scans by myself.
Alright.
Good choice.
Good choice, good choice.
They're not... They're not flying off the shelves like the
original movie.
Sequels never do as well, good, though.
I will admit.
I'm annoyed at that.
Only two copies?
Come on.
Only two copies for the newest sequel?
But they never do as well as the original.
Hey.
What?
That's right.
They are necessary.
I don't charge your late fees then I think you won't be able
to charge anybody late fees
and we can't have that this is my entire business apparently
blockbuster made like millions of dollars specifically on
just doing late fees like this was like their biggest
business making
and that's why the creators in Netflix was like fuck that
shit
one that that's fine with me like like is that a threat like
i'm fine with that if you want to return the next one lay
more money more money for me
oh see it says good credit it does well does well in the
market research
oh yes pick that movie up yes that here and then and then we
can put sci-fi back on the table I swear I had more sci-fi
films he wants for breakfast wait what did you want oh that
imagine if blockbuster bought Netflix though what would that
even look like like what what would the blockbuster stores
even do with netflix i do i don't know if i do if i didn't i
just buy it
guys we still have like seven more hours damn two adult
films it was like i can go again
oh wait poetry is you reserve this Oh my god, I found him.
Oh my god, I found him, guys.
Hello, sir.
What did you get?
You got...
Oh, a double-wammy new releases.
It's Waldo.
There you go.
Put that here.
Guys, I'm unhappy.
The sequel isn't fly off the shows Like the original, guys I
bought 20 copies I don't understand All my business moves
have been Have always worked Up to this point I don't
understand Me making a bad financial decision Say it ain't
so I knew it.
The sequels never do as well.
I got you.
You're right.
You're invested in franchises.
No, you can't.
What do you mean?
Poetry instead was beautiful.
It won 80 Oscars.
What is he looking at?
My office?
you like what you see
oh great sure you should be self-serve why the fuck am I
doing this myself you can self-serve in 7-11 you self-serve
and not blockbuster an old science fiction oh shit um an old
science fiction movie
old science fiction side oh there yo got you always had this
movie
oh they can't watch the sequel of senior ninja so clearly
you need 20 more copies of poetry instead it seems like a
really good argument because i can't argue against that
philio thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
simple-minded thank you super chat thank you thank you this
is just almost as bad when you bought all those dog shirts
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i mean i
can't argue with that logic guys
all right oh nope that is our science fiction oh wait i had
more drama here Oh my god, more potion is dead.
Because they're...
Why are they on the floor?
Because they don't deserve...
They don't deserve to be put on the shelf.
159.
I'm making a good profit.
Alright.
Day 9.
Oh, more science fiction is back.
What level is...
Oh, rewind.
Alright.
All right, put all these here.
Oh, Lafie.
These movies are not good enough.
They're not good enough to be on the main shelf.
If they were better movies, then maybe they wouldn't be on
the floor.
That's where I said it.
I don't put these guys here.
and I'll put this in the front oh holographic on top because
it's more expensive
no oh it's just a regular horror film who cares I have lots
of that on the floor
get out of here sci-fi oh shit not you
alright My bestseller.
Oh my god.
When does...
Oh, it ends.
It ends.
I was like, when does it end?
Oh, reserved.
Yeah.
They tried a little harder.
Maybe they get to be on the shelf.
Oh.
Whoa.
Double swirl tape.
Wild night tonight, girls.
Alright, oh my god, new movie genre.
I'm so close to level 6, guys.
Is there anything special?
Oh, plus 80% sci-fi.
Oh, fuck, okay.
I might actually have to start buying sci-fi.
Wait, okay, I can buy these later.
I'll buy these two tapes later.
But today's not sci-fi, though, so it doesn't matter.
Please come to my videotape store, please.
Yes, very new.
Oh my god, they're all coming in, doves.
There we go.
Oh my god, more videos.
Alright, we'll put that in the adult section.
Oh, what do you need help?
Oh, here.
Here you go.
Poetry is dead.
Here you go, sir.
And we'll put this here.
We have more poetry is dead.
And then we'll put you here.
Or then we'll put you here.
Alright.
I'm doing so well.
I'm such a successful business owner.
Ooh, fudge slime of your adult.
You know how to party, sir.
And I recommend you another fudge slime.
Got horror.
Of course.
idea.
Very good movie.
That's why it's on the floor.
I would say it's one of the best out there.
I'm in a drama film.
No, it's just all on the floor.
Yeah, the monkey movie is still not back yet.
I'm a little...
I think you're right.
I haven't seen a monkey movie in a while guys what happened
to my monkey movie what did why is it not back from the
store now
that you mention it that is pretty weird i
have more movies returned oh they've been returning these
like the whole day oh my god the double swirl is already
back this was like That was...
That
was rented out this morning.
I remember renting it out this morning.
I'm not sure you would, in fact.
That was $17.
Wait, this was rented out this morning, too.
Wait a minute.
Wait, I think he actually Picked it out from the floor I
didn't have sci-fi On the shelves Wait, he actually picked
the sci-fi Off the floor I remembered I didn't put sci-fi on
the shelves There was no sci-fi Wait
See, I told you guys I don't need shows Wait Yeah, I chucked
all sci-fi on the floor.
Oh, that placed one horror, one sci-fi.
Okay, I might have accidentally.
Maybe I placed one horror accidentally.
I won sci-fi accidentally in horror.
That sounds like something I do.
I'm going to double swirl.
I got you.
The floor is just...
If you think about it, the floor is just one big shelf.
oh shit okay no that all right we'll place three siphon oh
actually no
see I'm mine I'm mine I'm sad I invested 20 I'm so sad my
very first bad financial decision in my life my entire life
The only and the only one.
I hope this will teach.
Will I learn from it?
Only time will tell.
Never trust it.
Never trust Rotten Tomatoes, guys.
I want Slushy.
Damn.
I don't know if you want to slush you with that adult film.
a science fiction movie don't worry i got you it was on the
floor
wait all right and now i could put the sci-fi now sci-fi can
have his own shelf
yeah there you go just in time for the midnight rush
uh 13 dollars wait a minute must be people walking by,
right?
Oh, you're walking by, right?
No!
Oh, man.
Sir.
Please, you're the only person that...
No!
You know what?
I hate movies, so I don't own a VHS tape.
Liar!
You just hate me!
Oh.
Yeah, sure.
I got you.
Yes.
That's right.
This is a business, not a charity.
No handouts.
Yeah.
Wait, we have someone coming in for their film.
Right?
Where's the guy?
What's tomorrow?
Is tomorrow's sci-fi day?
Oh, shit.
Alright, it's time.
We gotta get the sci-fi.
Okay, sci-fi.
Alright.
Nope.
Alright, we gotta grab the sci-fi.
It's sci-fi day.
Alright, it's a meteor shower tomorrow.
80% sci-fi.
Shit, okay.
Get that shit out of here.
all right let's show sci-fi we gotta we gotta be a poser
it should be more sci-fi here oh wait there's no more wait
okay don't worry i can still buy more sci-fi drama sci-fi
sci-fi sci-fi sci-fi welcome to capitalism baby
It's like when, like, a celebrity or something is heading to
your town.
And then you change everything.
He's like, we've always loved you.
Sci-fi.
That's not...
This is just all sci-fi.
There you go.
Bam.
we have just enough shells just enough yeah we have action
now all right let the meteor shout that means I can watch
the meteors oh no is it still new are you still new it's
still new okay good it's okay guys the movie is still
considered new we still have one more day one more day
oh no i'm sorry poetry is dead you're not sci-fi just one
more day oh my god i've already been playing two hours it
does not feel like two hours i've been so locked in in my
successful business as a small business owner of not block
See, guys, even the new releases have to be on the floor.
Equality for everyone.
Look at that.
I don't discriminate.
Now I can just open it up while I do this.
Oh, wait.
It's all films.
I should put that up now.
These guys.
Oh, and they're finally back.
How is that not a late?
Oh, she knew how long she was going to rent it for.
She let me know in advance, guys.
And she...
She knew.
She let me know in advance.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
Sci-fi day.
Do I have more sci-fi coming in?
Oh my god, I do.
Oh, and I get action movies.
I should...
Oh, and I got more sci-fi.
Let's put that sci-fi in.
Oh, look at all that sci-fi.
Oh, never mind.
mind that's not sci-fi
we've always loved sci-fi in this store say well and prosper
as they say in Star Wars
alright one dollar token
true true
Oh, slushy.
Orange.
Yeah, it's like when there were wars in the stars, you know?
Why is it?
Where are the customers?
Oh, there they are.
Any other good Star Wars quote?
Well, I know, like, a Star Trek quote where he was like,
Spock, I'm your father.
Yeah.
An old movie.
I have a Sabbath.
There you go.
I need another shelf.
Let's see.
Ooh, I need, like, someone to give me $10.
Oh, I need, like, two more dollars now.
You're a wizard, Luke.
Now you're not even trying.
Trying to unlimited and beyond from my favorite sci-fi
movie, The Mandalorian.
All right, now I have enough for a shelf.
My action movie.
At $12 in my...
Wait, I couldn't expand.
I forgot.
I forgot about that.
I can expand.
Oh, yeah, I'm not expanding.
I'm not saving money at all.
I forgot about the whole expansion thing.
I know it was like the first thing I saw, too.
Wow, thank you.
Yeah, see, look at that.
$12 to my name.
Then I got $90 right off the...
Never punished.
Or was that from Back to the Future?
Unlimited and beyond.
There's my action movie.
How do I...
I'm a very, I, I love, wait, holographic.
I love sci-fi.
Wait, clock in.
Wait, okay, wait, we should.
I have more sci-fi?
More sci-fi!
I'm all in on the sci-fi.
Guys, the sci-fi is not flying out the shows.
It says plus 80%.
most intense here you go say was I given is this calendar
like out of date or some shit there's two shells worth of
sci-fi to boldly go where no Swift space wizard has gotten
before that's my sci-fi maybe I should put the drama movie
the bottom no then it won't be like no I shouldn't because
then then the shelves won't be organized a bad movie bad my
little friend say hello hmm that's my favorite Yoda quote
chat
Got it.
Hey.
That quote's Ashley from Dude.
No, they took...
Dude took inspiration from Star Trek to have that quote.
That's why it's very similar.
That was lie, too, about the fucking...
The sci-fi forecast.
I spent it all on sci-fi.
I went all in.
They always say to go all in.
Yeah, action.
Must have an oldie here.
Where's the fuck is the meteor shower?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, wait, it's going up.
I don't think they know what...
Oh wait, maybe it's just persp- I don't know, it looks like
it's going up.
It's like- What the fuck?
The reverse medias.
I was gonna say, wait a minute.
They don't look like they're going across.
The fine...
Okay, that's- dumb.
How am I supposed to know what the fuck I put?
Well, let's grab some dino gummies.
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to.
Alright, now I won't put dino gummies.
Yummy.
Alright.
There you go.
Bye.
Making less and less money, guys.
Am I making some poor decisions no it's the customers it
can't be me it's you don't get out they don't know what's
hip anymore all right what's today oh my god there's another
new release oh my god it's almost horror day you know what
that means i knew my investment in horror would pay off real
grab we'll make this the drama shelf now now we have a shelf
for every job genre.
What are that?
Now... No!
Poetry!
It's dead!
It's finally dead!
What do I do?
No!
I can't believe it's finally happened they
were so good to me oh my god just just started rewinding
right on me oh my god forgot to press that they killed him
it's time to put in the discount bid
okay I'll just well I mean I can just open the store now.
I'll do this well.
Oh, poetry is dead.
You were so good to me.
Oh, wait.
We need that double swirl.
Oh my god, people are already renting.
They're ready to give me money.
What?
It's the best way to restock.
okay gotta make sure see look at that put it here and I'll
put it here okay maybe if you have more shelves you will
learn more stop saying wild things if they really wanted
that movie they'll pick it up on the floor clearly don't
want it hard enough all
right all right oh good choice good choice please pay the
late fee that's right i would like if you don't be more
careful though that's how i make majority of my business
make majority of my profits oh the donald gummies nice good
choice sir good choice
Okay, more rewind time.
Oh, you don't feel surprisingly a very popular.
Oh, rewind.
Can you restock anything?
No?
Oh, my God.
No one's picking the poetry instead.
You were so good to me.
Oh, I got a great movie.
That's right.
I sure do, ma'am.
I sure do.
That's good.
I did surprisingly rent a couple more, and I thought I would
for this one.
Yeah.
That there.
And the not poetry is dead down there.
then what you like i've been waiting on this all right six
dollars oh my god they're more expensive i should just go
all in on the adult films industry and grape juice for it
wild lady i hear you can rent movies on demand on your tv
you don't need no don't say that it's gonna fail that to
watch a movie um watch a movie and not physical tape you're
saying wow shit
physical meter will never die there's no future in that
yeah who would want to watch a movie on dial up exactly
bad movie
yeah that's right imagine imagine buy something you don't
physically own couldn't be me how the fuck do I do with all
these poetry is dead copies guys I might not have thought
this through very well
let's see more films oh my god the monkey movies back.
here.
And I'll sneak one poetry instead.
Right here.
Just like the good old days.
Oh, today's a slow day.
Not a lot of customers today.
There is a Pooge Day.
Wait, that means wait.
Wait, the garden.
Oh my god.
Forgot the check on the guy.
I could have bought more adult films!
Hey.
Got you?
Alright, wait.
I have enough.
How about this, guys?
Alright.
I think I have enough.
I'll put one shelf, and that shelf is just miscellaneous.
And you can't You can't cry about how it's not sorted
correctly, guys.
This is my miscellaneous shelf.
Where my floor videos go to.
Alright.
This is the whatever I have goes there.
There we go.
Oh my god, I have a lot of videos.
Wait, this is action?
No, that's drama.
is action wait how come action is the same color as the
other stuff oh there's a lot of people this is the floor
shelf shelf that's now on the shelf
these i need i literally need like two more one more level
and i can hire staff maybe the staff will pick up my my
floor videos
know you do know our late wait what color do you want it you
charged by the day right locked yourself in that room
tonight sir good for you wait tomorrow's horror night is it
or is a new release day I've lost track all there's too much
oh shit you want change how about you can how about you
leave
Alright, what's tomorrow?
Oh my god, it's another new release.
Oh my god, tomorrow's a new day, guys.
Guys, I...
Guys...
Oh, I am making less and less.
Oh, yes!
Okay.
Wait, where...
Oh, there's my...
I was like, where's my store?
Where's my store?
Okay.
I'll put this here.
Alright, we can finally hide.
someone.
Alright, who do we want?
Alright.
She's slow.
Why the fuck?
Oh.
Alright.
He has a strong... And he handles complaints.
49 a day.
Henry, get in here, Henry.
Alright.
We'll put you on.
We'll do return station.
You can do the... Actually, we'll do checkout.
You go handle the checkout counter for me.
What I said to be... I knew you were going to sell nothing
but Batman.
What do you mean?
I'm making so much money right now.
Wait, go to work.
What are you doing here?
Oh, I'm not working for free.
I mean.
Well, ready, completely.
All right.
Okay.
All right, guys.
I think this time.
We'll start with...
and then
what do you I you decline what do you mean I've been dealing
with complainers all day it's your first you didn't even go
in the front yet it's literally your first day who have you
been who's been complaining to you you said you're an expert
at handling complaints how I literally paid you extra
because you are good at handling complaints gotta respect
the hustle he's the complainer I was like it's the first day
what the fuck do you mean you've been handling complaints
all day I'll
go into this show
action better start early
all right go here okay now the new strategy for new releases
is when we start having no more of the copies then I'll
start buying it more that's the new strat guys
these are actions so no i don't have a lot of these i got
them for free i mean that's why it broke so easily it's
because i got it for free that it's breaking so easily
flying off the shelves, I will say.
I found them in the dump.
Honestly, they were donated, so I won't be surprised.
There's action.
Double swirl.
Drama.
I'm going to put them all here.
I mean, a staff member, it does help out a lot.
I will say.
say and then one more return okay maybe i'll have more free
action movies let me check wait do i still have nobody's i
knew it see guys i felt nobody's renting it now wait is it
because i don't have a sign that says it's new
okay you know people just put the post asleep wake up wake
up you know like when they just put a poster over the top of
another poster after the promotion is done it's just easier
guys after the promotion is done
meme reaction films like the fuck is that oh my that's
holographic wait i'm grabbing that shit that's hot oh my god
look at this that's the only thing special about this movie
oh oh i got it here you go man see nobody's place picking
anything from the the the floor shelf videos guys maybe
because it wasn't that good in the first place that's why
it's on the floor it's
the shiny poke mats wait is that oh horror time oh my god i
have so many horror films too it's your time to shine i have
that the blaze runner
that's almost 9 p.m all right my floor shelf
and then we'll put that i should have a shelf dedicated to
old releases old new releases i wish we can rename these old
new releases there
you go hey who said hey just went and they start getting one
or two broken tapes that no don't say that i'm not made of
money I run up not blockbuster Wolfen thank you Super Chat
thank you thank you I think I have enough My old new
releases Oh I have a television I should buy a shelf Oh my
god is that a television
Where the fuck do I
There we go I don't know what the television is good for But
I got it I should have read it.
Like, it doesn't even tell me.
It just says TV.
What the fuck do I do with TV?
Oh my god, I could buy a robot.
Wait, I can...
Oh,
wait.
The dealer is here.
Oh my god, I should have saved money for more adult films.
It's fine.
I got double merchant action.
Wait, what?
surprise oh hey sugar bum surprise me with it oh wash my
body builder in bed with like oh wait this is new double
merchant action don't worry i got you
wait i should run out of action movies i do love hearing
screams in the background of my movie rental store.
Nobody picked anything in my mix section.
That's crazy.
Alright.
Oh, hey there.
Hey, are you excited for my store?
Would you...
Do you...
Want a pamphlet?
Alright, I gotta have another...
Oh, it's horror time.
So...
Alright, we gotta stock up on the horror.
No!
Just when we need horror.
Wait.
The new release is horror related.
Wait, this might be where it goes hard.
Wait.
Guys, this might be where the new release comes in clutch.
Chat.
Characons, this is it.
Or sneak one in here.
This is where it comes in clutch.
This is what he's made for.
Guess what you...
Oh.
Would you want this specific copy or the other copies I have
in my hand?
Oh my god, everybody returned horror films too.
Which is good for me.
oh my god they're actually flying off the shells right now
oh shit
i knew my early investment in horror was a good idea guys i
fucking knew it you all laughed i went all in
i knew going all in in wouldn't fuck me over
I got you.
Yeah.
And more drama.
Oh.
Someone missed out on the...
That's smart.
They waited until the movie was...
Not as popular and then went in.
There's that.
Yeah, I was like, that looks like a drama film.
So that's cheaper now.
Oh, reserve.
And they waited until it was cheaper before they came back.
What the fuck?
Oh, he wanted to rent.
Oh, hello.
What happened?
Why was she mad?
Oh, was it because of the late fees?
That's on you.
Oh, that's fine.
Oh, my God.
She tried to rent.
She tried to rent a lot of them.
Yeah, what did Henry do?
He said he was good at handling.
He did say that.
What the fuck?
They never pushed my shit.
Henry!
What is going on, Henry?
What are you saying to these people?
People lie on their resume all the time, Doki.
Oh, hey, Waldo.
My man.
Alright, we'll put sci-fi.
and then got the adult films here and that lady got really
mad that she couldn't about the late feet then maybe like
you know maybe it shouldn't have gone too hard she going too
hard to the sun too close to the sun
wait why is there a reserve though which one's reserved
which one
Which one is reserved, guys?
Why is it just there?
Let's see it.
We need like, we do need a...
One time I mixed up my VHS and local video store.
When I returned it, they wanted me to pay the late piece
cost.
Plus the cost of the VHS?
I told them to fuck off.
That...
Oh, that's too much.
He said, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I can't believe it.
I mean, you could just...
like swap like swap it you
just like swapped it back bro stop you told me this guy lied
on his resume this guy this guy definitely lied on his
resume I've never had three customers in a row be so angry I
might need a new I need to hire a new one.
Wait, what has she been waiting on?
Bad dreams.
Oh, I do.
Yeah, thank God I bought five this time instead of 20.
Wait, what?
Oh, shit, Elm Street!
Okay, you gotta pick it yourself, I guess.
I was not...
I was like, what about this other movie?
What about...
I was just like, are you sure you want that movie?
about this other movie that i have here you want an old
classic old okay this is a classic
here's an oldie but a goodie most like it's from the 20 fee
for returning a broken tape it sucks getting your turn
broken but you charge point yeah to the person who broke it
exactly uh wolf friend thank you this super chat thank you
thank you i agree Wake up!
Get back to work!
You can sleep when you clock out.
I pay $45 a day.
You can afford a car with that money.
Alright, I have a new shelf.
It'll be old new releases.
The Has-Bins.
Alright, let's buy a new shelf.
It'll be my Has-Bins shelf.
Where is...
Where is it?
Where legends go to die.
Right next to the...
Let's fuck it.
That's right next to Screaming TV.
Oh, how you fallen.
Oh, my old friend.
How you fallen.
One day someone will love you like when you were new.
Oh wait, this was reserved.
you have a drama i sure do wait i sure do i sure treat him
well
i like the hat they're like oh my god in an adult film to go
with it
they're like those movie stars that you to be popular what
is it called i mean i think i did made good i had good
business with the horror films yeah the game has been really
fun
all right oh my god 300 dollars 300 dollar runies this time
all right let's see oh the floating reserves is still here
yeah oh this must be the movie that the guy like through.
Wait, I had a reserve for a poetry is dead?
Wait, what's that?
Oh, shit.
I should be paying more attention.
What's up, Liz?
Yes, I do.
I think I do.
I should have more action films.
Ew.
Alright, we're open.
Please come to my store.
I have a family to feed, and the family is the family of
one, or two, including dad.
you know what i'm gonna hide i'm i don't want to rewind
stuff anymore i
applicants average our return station energetic never falls
asleep strong will never take a sick day i like that i miss
me level 20 oh my god i can't What the fuck?
You already sleeping on the job?
There you go.
Alright, it's time to rewind.
Oh, shit.
I forgot about this one.
Put Henry on the...
No, I'd rather do this myself.
I...
Oh, I could put him on the return...
Yeah, but then I would have nothing to do while he does this
cashier thing.
I might as well do this myself.
Oh.
Wait, I was gonna say, oh my god, we finally sold out of
that.
Let's see right here.
Boar tree is dead.
Look at that, guys.
Nothing's on the floor this time.
Chat, I'm getting better at this.
At being a business owner.
Oh my god, there's so many horror films.
Okay, we might actually have to change the channel.
I realized that I thought it would be funny, but then now
I'm like, this might be a little annoying.
Hearing the screams next to me.
Oh, reserve.
Whoops.
Oops.
Sorry.
I'm fumbling.
Too many videos in my hand.
Oh, reserve is here.
Yes.
Oh, poetry is there.
got you should be here oh this should be here and then here
put it on the floor I was gonna say I'm proud of myself
there's no videos on the floor this time all right grab this
all right we won put you here we did rewind I love that
rewind be cotton.
That's such a good movie.
From Jack Black.
And I forgot who was the other guy.
Oh, sure.
Do I have an old one on the floor?
I do.
Get rid of the floor videos first.
I'm so locked in.
No!
Oh my god.
I'm losing the action films.
So fast now.
Okay, I actually need to buy more action movies.
movies
it here horror drama action action or all
right the has-been shelf all right let's go buy more action
films market or action action you know what I can afford a
mixed bag.
There must be action in here.
There's actually no action in my mixed bag.
There's actually...
Alright.
One action.
That's fine.
One action is good enough.
Uh, 2K, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This dude reminds me of a guy from my town's rental store.
Always asleep.
Always spelling like a Bob Marley concert.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That guys.
life right now for sure I will put you two here and then see
guess what would you like ma'am oh you reserved this here
you go all right this is sci-fi on all right drama sci-fi
goes on the floor
oh what day is it today it's saturday okay it's sci-fi day
soon
all right oh what would you like sir a bad adult film is
that possible is that oh there is one the monkey is a bad
but it's our best-selling
be bad.
It's our best one yet.
Do not.
And here.
Oh, we ran out of snacks.
I didn't even notice.
The fudge.
Oh my god, the fudge line went by fast.
I mean, it is next to the it's next to the adult section we
know why there you go
the astronaut in here or tree is dead might need more shells
i oh i could buy this i don't know how we're all the way in
the corner That must be the last reservation.
Oh, drama?
I got you.
The holographic one.
Wait.
Come to my store.
You walked past my store.
I saw you.
Please come to my store.
Oh.
Trying to walk away, but don't worry.
Now I can walk into my store.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
I guess you have no taste.
Get with the times, old woman!
Where are we met?
Oh,
this one.
Wait, where is it?
That path live off the floor.
Oh.
Oh, he's coming in.
Okay, slowly restock my shows.
Oh, phone's ringing.
Our routine now.
Yeah.
We have a beautiful routine going in.
Oh my god, I'm making so much money now, guys.
We're making it rain!
We have a new movie genre soon!
And then we're gonna have popcorn!
Guys, I'm so locked in.
successful.
There's no way my business will fail now.
There's no way.
Nothing can stop me and not Blockbuster.
No new invention's gonna get me out of business.
Yeah, can Netflix have popcorn?
I don't think so.
Where's Netflix's popcorn machine, huh?
Oh, I'm a real man.
All right, it's real man's time.
We're too big to fail now.
We're like the banks.
All right, we're going to get a big shelf for that.
I know my market.
All right, oh, it should be right here next to the adult and
snack.
All right.
So I can take advantage of the people walking by.
Grab the early customers in now.
There we go.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Hello?
Mushy Mushy!
Alright.
Got that.
Right here.
Uh.
Oh, it's still new.
It's still new.
fresh.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Oh, shit, I'm too busy to rewind.
Wake up!
Alright.
We won.
My reserve.
Hey.
Or.
New, new.
Oh, wait.
Wait, it's a slow burner.
Wait, look at that.
We almost sold out.
I knew it.
I knew you would.
You would cash out eventually.
I fucking knew it.
It was a slow burn.
But we made it.
I knew you would pop off in the end.
The long game.
Exactly.
It was playing a long game.
Those 20 copies finally made it.
all right oh we got them back oh one is reserved there's a
reserve copy there it is uh here you go
uh oh my god so many people are returning their tapes right
now no stop stop doing that how am i gonna get my late fees
you keep returning them on time
can be level 20 for to like have a second staff member oh
are you looking for a man or I'm put this so I'm back and I
got you and then poetry is dead double swirl it's action no
this is drama oh my Oh my gosh, I still have more tapes.
Oh, I think I have too many tapes now.
I have too many movies.
By reserve.
I don't have enough hands for this.
Uh, action.
Sci-fi.
Oh, shit, reserve.
Sir, please wait.
Oh.
thank god i don't have to do a cash register anymore okay
sci-fi sci-fi horror action oh my god i haven't even put the
romance in yet i gotta order the romance my free 10 movies
romance what's tomorrow tomorrow's sci-fi day or i got you
guess what would you like bad dreams are mill oh my hand are
full give me a sec i gotta put this on the romance section
the floating surgeon in love table for two with our driver
our driver wait then that means what happened to the why is
it not my driver
why wait a minute oh shit sorry oh that's what you wanted i
I just threw her red.
I didn't even know what she asked for.
I mean, if that's what she wanted, I'll...
Alright.
Another happy customer, guys.
Another happy customer.
It's Romance doing well, I can't tell.
Alright, we're gonna have to have a full sci-fi table again.
Okay, let's see.
Last day.
Alright, then Tuesday.
In two days, I get to...
Do I have anything new?
Oh, the Clarence bin!
This is what we need.
Okay, this is what we need.
We have to put all the oldies in there.
Alright, smoothie.
There you go.
Maybe we should buy more romance, smoothie.
movies.
I feel I need more action and romance.
I'm gonna buy that.
Action.
Romance.
Oh, holographic.
Okay.
Romance.
Is that sci-fi?
Sci-fi?
Okay, that's good timing too.
Because tomorrow's sci-fi day the only issue is that i hate
rewinding
return section is not that fun to do i'm gonna make henry do
it for me next time
why does no one like the mixed section i told you guys the
floor videos don't do as well on the floor people don't like
the floor videos they like the videos so much they would
have rented picked it up on the floor
oh my god it's the robotic convention day oh my god there he
is hello there hello mr roboto all right sir i need you sir
sir sir sir i need you to rewind tapes for me actually i can
do it
myself i'm to my i'm to my vhs tape store all right rewind
time that's good i'm getting all the sci-fi tapes back all
right so all right it's fine i'll group it all up here
and then we're going to rewind this
i'm going to put this here elm street you're going in here
you're going in the has been corner now
um hey where is the guy are you asking for a raise no dental
insurance no benefits nothing I don't even get free I don't
even have popcorn no I quit okay wait wait a minute oh yeah
I don't need you I have ah fuck okay I have oh shit he's
more expensive okay I have Philip
Oh god, Philip, please come back fast.
Philip, where are you, Philip?
Where are...
Where's Philip?
Guy.
He's so...
I can't believe after everything I gave him.
Which was like, not much, but after everything I gave him.
He's so...
God, what's that word?
Doesn't appreciate the stuff I do for my employees.
So entitled.
What did you give him?
A job.
Is that in this market?
I am firing you.
You know, you go do the return station because you're
apparently really good at it.
So inconsiderate.
Oh, wait.
Actually, no.
I just realized this check you out is worse.
You're so intangible and considerate.
Yeah, sure, I got you.
Oh, I thought it's sci-fi day.
Why are my sci-fi still up there?
Give me closing my eyes for a suit.
Wake up.
Check it out.
I'm doing returns.
It's sci-fi day!
Everyone's buying everything but sci-fi!
Oh my god, it's all horror.
Alright, then.
This.
Oh wait, I have more space right here.
Oh, God, I'm losing track.
I'm losing track of all the videos.
There's so many videos.
Oh, here you go.
Poetry is dead.
I don't understand.
I thought it's sci-fi day.
Pick up the sci-fi!
There's a robotic convention going on!
Okay, uh...
Oh, it's not...
Oh, wait.
Because it's sci-fi, put sci-fi oh i am so smart there's a
sci-fi convention and i'm putting a sci-fi show on
here you go all right rewind people are seeing every sci-fi
movie ever made i mean to be fair like that sort of makes
sense because if they're like big ass nerds
there you go
never calling me oh wait that should be reserved it's
not doing so is it because it's mixed i have a feeling like
when it's mixed it doesn't i i think like putting in the mix
section might not been the smartest thing i've done today i
think actually they divide it or they won't sell it That's
so dumb.
That's so fucking stupid.
Because my mix section has not been rolling off the shelves.
Honestly.
Nobody has been like...
Nobody has been like putting and picking stuff out of this
section here.
I honestly feel that people don't like it when there's no
obvious genre.
Okay.
Oh, that's the last one.
Oh.
They said 80% more rentals.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
They picked it up from there.
Theory busted.
They picked it up from the shelf.
All right, let's see.
I don't have enough shelves.
I can't afford it.
Guys.
I can't afford.
I'm not made of money.
I want a VHS store.
Wait, what's tomorrow?
Oh, another new release.
All right, that's good.
All right.
We'll wait for the new release.
And then it's also more adult films.
Hello.
I caught the worst code.
I couldn't even...
No.
That's right.
that's fucking right no one is special in my store we treat
everyone equally
maybe I should oh wait
portrait is dead demented doctor sci-fi oh wait our movies
came off of this show that's good
alright that should be good All right.
Good day of work, Henry.
We didn't need the other guy.
Wait, I think that's Philip.
Wait, which guy is this?
I've lost track of the guys I've hired.
I...
Wait, guys, which guy was this guy?
Oh, hello, tell.
Ooh, maybe 15.
Okay, maybe 10.
Hello, tell.
All
right, and then we should have, we're open, and then we put
them to stand up.
And then we'll put this area.
And then it's rewind time.
Oh, oh, reserved.
Oh, no!
I don't have a lot of these!
Oh, what would you like, lady?
Um, give me a sec.
Uh, poetry is dead.
Uh, drama.
Let's see.
New.
Oh, wait, now we can change the channel.
There we go.
We'll change it here.
All right, you want the teddy bear?
Oh, my God.
we're so popular thank god we're the only rental video store
in this country
all right sir
guys i think i think i have a problem guys guys i don't know
how to stop
i can't guys i'm having trouble stopping guys every i just
so
This doesn't stop.
I just have so many videos.
Okay, romance is definitely dead.
We don't have as many people renting romance.
I should play the movie.
Okay, we're not...
There's only two channels.
I spent $200 and I don't have cable.
Oh.
Okay.
drama
all right though okay i should actually eventually i'm gonna
buy you know what i'm gonna do it i'm gonna fucking do it
guys i'm gonna buy a bigger shelf that's right that's okay
the way this guy's asleep wake up philip all right let me
give that up to do it.
We'll start with the horse shelf.
I should have to reposition stuff, though.
Okay, wait.
Whoa, it's the one at it.
Okay, I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna buy a bigger shelf.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
That's a little awkward.
Okay, um...
I'll move you here and then...
Oh, shit!
Nice!
Free videos.
Put you here.
Put all the hordes in here.
There you go.
Here.
And then...
Yellow.
There you go.
Look at that.
All the hordes!
all the time and then I'll put you and we're gonna put you
oh I don't know you you're like the miscellaneous oh you can
go here look and then you grab all the horror stuff out of
here and put you here oh my god i'm doing guys who is she
what happened to all my videos on the floor dokey don't
worry we still have one video on the floor oh my gosh she's
serious about her business now oh wait one what happened to
her not my dokey not
what do you've changed Ever since your business started
booming, you forgot about the little people.
What happened to you, Doki?
Here.
Wait, it's Tuesday.
Oh, today's Tuesday.
All right.
It's adult video day.
All right, it's sci-fi.
It's nice that Poetry is dead.
out that's what i like to see
hi hello oh an adult movie i got you i have all the adult
movies out here um chapel is joking
oh oh he's here oh shit movies wait okay after put these
away
action oh my god he's here he's here with my adult films
we left the stern behind the depressed tentacle i might as
well grab that he's depressed we gotta help him
ma 'am oh did he through wait why was he wait what did he do
okay the shrimp mate is in for a treat whoa poor male man
you're mine this should go I should have space here in my
miscellaneous I
think we did well today the depressed tentacle is absolute
fired 10 out of 10 hundred percent on Ryan Tomatoes.
Alright, ma'am.
I need you to leave the store.
I'm thriving right now.
They all doubted my business.
Said it shouldn't work.
Said I'm crazy for trying to open up a video rental store.
Says, who owns VHS tapes now?
No, do I know?
It's cool.
Now, it's hip.
It's retro.
It's like vinyls.
boat with vhs's bringing them back it's hip I get popcorn oh
my god it's popcorn day
alright nice that's right can Netflix give you this bam
popcorn hello Matt we gotta wait two more levels and I get
the clearance bin guys guys we got we're almost there two
more levels all
right oh no my broken tape
it's all right i can get it all back at this point it might
be me that's breaking them
wait what day is today oh it's just Just a regular day.
But I didn't tend to be extra expecting more customers.
Oh, wait, that claim.
Oh, I claimed everything.
Oh, I didn't claim this.
I got good customer service.
I got first hire.
Put a movie in the trash.
Off the books.
Oh, my God.
I'm fucking rolling.
Rolling in XP right now.
Hello.
Give me a bad movie.
Bad.
Here you go.
Alright, back to rewinding time.
Alright, uh, poop.
Poop.
Oops.
Oh shit, poop.
Oh, fuck, okay.
Floor it goes.
Floor.
Oh my gosh, guys.
I might have too many horror films.
Oh.
Oh, everyone.
Oh, shit.
Uh, oh.
Mushy, Mushy.
Sure, I reserved that.
I don't know if I had.
I was so confident that I have one.
guys I don't know how many videos I have now I think I have
I think I rented too many I think I bought too many
drama drama drama oh that's definitely not drama okay body
part
Oh.
Oh, so many people are reserving today.
No!
What movie was that?
Alright, doesn't matter.
Sci-fi.
Alright, poetry is dead.
Alright, sci-fi.
Oh.
Here you go, sir.
I still have to rewind.
Oh, preserve.
Another hotel hell reserve.
I'm glad I bought five of this one.
The color violet.
That one has not been doing so well.
Like I've had five.
But I always see one of them.
Still in my store.
Alright.
It looks like.
Alright let me see.
It could be a sci-fi shelf.
But I do.
Still have a lot of sci-fi.
I don't know.
I'm trying to decide what I want to make this shelf as, you
know?
It couldn't be.
You know, I could put it...
It would be my Elm Street.
Just this one.
Oh, my God.
He's making popcorn.
He's doing it.
He's selling the popcorn.
Yeah.
What do I want?
to buy what was i trying to save up for i've lost track oh i
need more action movies oh my god i have no action movies in
the wait it could be in the mix oh wait no action action
yeah it's almost action day give me a sec the manager is
busy last movie i ran to was so bad I broke the I have anger
and well of course I'm gonna charge one what the fuck I
don't care you have anger management you broke the tape like
what how how does it not stop you from breaking the second
tape oh my god forgot about my snacks okay oh oh
the dino gummies are going off the shelf I might actually
have to get rid of these chips these all right put the
chicken in here chips has not been selling so well another
one all right give me a sec she wants hotel hell wow is that
i have a broken fee is that scam charge fee that's right
what do you mean you broke the tape you try you get charged
it's them's the rules don't like it go and find another
video rent a store oh you can't I'm the only one oh you
can't might as well fly to another country if you want to
find one
that's right I got the monopoly and the monopoly is one oh
nice all my adult films came back
oh there's a lot of films coming back today.
Gangster temptation.
Hey.
Wake up!
You clock out when I tell you to clock out.
Oh, wait.
All the new releases, though.
Oh my god, wait.
Okay, wait.
How many... Oh my god.
You know what that means.
Home.
Hotel hell.
More hotel hell?
That's right.
More hotel hell.
Oh my god.
I'll just do that.
Did you hear about hotel hell?
Did you hear our hell hotel?
It's a classic.
I'll box them in.
it's just all hotel hell
that's cool well now I have a box now I have a now oh now I
have a now I have oh it's alright
alright it's all hotel hell or hell hotel
yeah um
And here.
And then poetry is dead.
And drama.
Oh my god, I swear to you guys, it's always the action
movies that break.
They get too intense with them.
They think it's real life.
Oh, well, I'll put this away first.
The drama, I don't like how the drama and the action movie
covers are like very similar.
Romance.
It's so hard.
Oh wait, I forgot about that.
this guy there you go and they get too excited in the action
movies
oh all right or is it whoops all right here you go uh
there you go i think everything is as balanced as it should
be now i can just wait what day is it?
19.
Alright, tomorrow is action day, so we gotta make sure we
have enough action movies for tomorrow.
Alright, action, action.
Ooh.
Action.
Is today Thursday?
Oh!
It's adult movie day, too!
My dealer's here!
Hey!
Wake up, Philip!
You don't want to know what I did to Henry!
That's why Henry disappeared after he quit.
I don't know what happened to him.
I just read it on the news.
Nobody knows what happened to him.
Poor Henry.
Hope he's okay.
He just disappeared right after quitting.
Is that weird, guys?
It's so weird.
I bet Henry wish he stayed
Many watch movies honoring New Release Day Spooky season
We need the Clarence bin Stat There's like a Customizable
sign I don't know what that How much of a Custom How much
customization can I put?
It's only on outside.
Where are I going to put it?
Oh.
See the pumpkin?
Moving on.
There you go.
Oh, that's my return.
That's why it's beeping.
That's the video.
I just noticed that.
I was like, what the fuck is that beeping noise?
Like.
I just realized what the beeping noise is.
I must have a bad movie on the floor, right?
Yeah, I do.
I was like, what the fuck keeps beeping?
Oh, was I not buying bad movie, action movies?
I bought all of them already.
I think I bought all of them already.
Let's see.
That's where it came from.
Hey Wash my body Builder Instead Action Wait, that's the
same bodybuilder Oh my god, he's made it Shout out to that
guy He's made it guys From porn star
Let's see it From porn star to Oscar Nominee Okay I don't
know what to put for this.
I don't even know where to put it.
Yeah?
Oh, I do.
Full throttle, T-Rex!
Come to my store, please.
I...
These are my wife will leave me.
Oh, shit.
The phone's ringing.
Oh, yeah, I have this.
it's like right over here
are the plat points how close am I how close am I to wait I
might be able to claim another thing no I've claimed
everything possible I'm at oh my god two more guys guys the
moment I get the clearance bin I'm out I'm out guys I swear
I just need to get clearance oh wait he dropped oh they
dropped they didn't pay the fees
I swear to God guys It's the last job One last job guys and
I'm out The moment I get that clearance fee Clearance bin
I need to get rid of all these movies I keep buying
Guys I think I bought too many movies
Yeah, I have that.
I have three free movies outside.
What do you mean?
There's no such thing as free movies.
How dare you say that?
What, you think you can go on a website, just watch stuff
for free?
Wait, near the bowling club?
Wait, is there actually?
No, there isn't.
I knew it.
I knew there isn't.
That's my store.
What do you mean?
On the ground?
Oh my god, there's free movies on the ground!
Oh my god.
We're rich!
That's what we needed.
Look at these photographs.
But in video form.
Yay!
Christmas movies!
In... in...
On Halloween?
I mean, I mean, I guess...
I guess it's close to Halloween.
A Christmas.
Makes sense.
That does make sense.
Wait, why is it mixed?
what what what doesn't belong here they're
all action what the fuck you mean mix oh I told you the
cover all looks the same
oh damn it no my dog oh I
forgot to
did it oh
my god does he want to raise oh
okay i was like what do you mean
whoops give me a sec i gotta talk to philip hey all right
philip philip why aren't you working i'm feel i need you to
stay that's right get it back to work your drama got you
don't you know you gotta call five days ahead if you're
getting sick it's fine I have so many horror films
you gotta call it five days early if you want to clock in
and out if you want to clock out of work
we have a fucking business to run I really need to go to
the... We don't have bathrooms here.
Where are you going?
Oh, we do.
What are you sick, Tokey.
Oh, you don't love the company?
We're family.
Tokey, I will be sick in the next Thursday and Friday.
You don't care about your family?
I hate that.
Hey, boss.
I'm gonna be dead next.
to have Monday off.
There was the lime juice.
Alright, get back to work.
There you go.
Alright.
Holy shit.
A lot of people wanted sci-fi today.
The action area isn't getting as much business as I like.
Ooh, but the romance.
People were feeling frisky.
yesterday.
Whoa!
Ah, fuck.
Oh, my god.
My romance section is actually all sold out.
Yeah.
Tomb.
Oh.
God, I have so many videos.
Oh, my God, it keeps...
So many people keep returning videos!
Hi.
Morning.
There we go.
Uh, full throttle T-Rex.
That's good.
We actually need more action back here.
Zechra, thank you for the 10 gift of chips.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, we'll put it here.
Drama.
Hmm.
Oh my god, I'm losing track.
Oh, horror's out now.
All right.
Alright, there we go.
We got it all in.
Uh, drama here.
Uh, romance.
Poetry is dead.
Alright, there we go.
I think everything is organized neatly.
Alright, we're gonna need...
Oh, yeah, the Christmas movies!
Christmas!
Yay!
Alright, we're gonna a shelf for that i feel like christmas
isn't like super popular all season so i'm just gonna grab a
small shelf i feel like and it should be next to the adult
sex as it should be uh
I think it goes hand in hand together, guys.
My Christmas films and my adult videos.
The Tori Makers.
This is the treasure season.
Let's put this here.
I think it works out.
Oh, don't he thinks so, guys.
Remember what I said?
I think the adult section and the Christmas section goes
ahead.
I mean, was that wrong?
What was that?
That man sure thought so.
They're on the same wavelength, guys.
He thought so.
X-Mist movie and X-rated movies?
They both have the letter X in it.
You know what Santa always says?
Ho ho.
Is that what he always says, guys?
Ho ho ho.
Reaction.
And I think if we don't...
i'll put this here and then here you go there you go oh my
god our new release is sold out today what the fuck oh
someone got mad wait no not the oh it's the guy that's
trying to rent the fucking iron reserve oh i have we up one
more that's good
Can you help me pick a good one?
Let's see, here we go.
Wow.
Yeah.
Triple the X's means triple the Christmases, right?
Extra jolly, as they say.
Where are they all on?
Oh, wait, I put them on the floor.
Why are these all on the floor?
Oh, right.
I did that.
That was me.
I did that Close to Oh yeah I feel like I shouldn't Because
I need to pay $42 To that guy
Alright Ma'am I need you to hurry up Oh Double swirl and a
chip bag Do I need to restock?
No Francis thank you for the super chat Thank you thank you
Oh I do longer.
Of course I know that.
That's my own business.
Alright, 326.
Level 9.
Oh my god, we're almost there.
We're one level away.
Akoba!
Thank you for the 20 gift of chefs!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you so much!
Holy shit!
Thank you!
Alright, open.
We're open for business.
Oh my god, they're going off the shelves.
It's like, I feel like I always, like, get, like,
last-minute rentals for the new releases.
The only issue is that I don't know what to do with 20 of
them after.
It's a little bit of a problem.
Just a little bit.
Okay, here.
Yes?
A romance movie.
I got you.
Our inmate's first date.
The perfect one.
Oh.
Be kind, rewind.
Action.
Drama.
Oh, drama.
Any more action movies?
Oh, wait, Philip!
$19!
Get out of here!
An old science fiction.
There you go.
Get back to work!
Why on you, rewind?
He wants a $19 raise!
Guys, how dare he?
Let's see, action, action.
Science fiction, floor, floor.
Adult action.
Kids these days.
Back in my day, I was happy.
I was happy working for like, for free.
Not now, though.
I said, back in my day.
It's not my day anymore.
But, like, when I was his age.
Lies.
No integrity.
Yeah, I knew it, guys.
I knew the Xmas pal is not gonna go us.
Not gonna.
Do as well.
Bad action filmed.
Why?
Oh, I do.
The super gingerbread men
That's right
Soon soon he'll turn into like those at the McDonald's
machines
That's action
He should be lucky he hasn't turned into a McDonald's
ordering machine yet
Taking the jobs.
Okay, now I can expand.
I won't buy a B section.
Okay, let's grab B.
Oh, shit.
That's an expansion expansion.
Put this all the way back here.
Wait, I think I can finally...
Wait, I heard snoring.
Wake up!
Philip!
Why can't I put a sign here?
There you go.
Oh wait, I should make it so that...
Oh shit.
Oh no, what did they hang up?
Oh!
Yeah, that cost $250.
Yes.
Yes, you're so right.
And...
There you go.
And then...
Oh, shit, I forgot about the sign above it.
Next to it.
And then...
There you go.
Wait, actually...
It should be like this.
Oh, wait, actually.
It should be like...
Like this.
There you go.
all right and then we'll put this back here the action
section oh got a bad movie um oh my gosh everything is so
far away though now actually was that bad idea everything is
so far away what thank you the super chat thank you thank
you unfortunately there's no oh man You don't have to walk
so far.
Yeah, the customers.
Wait, I don't know if I like this.
You don't have to walk so far now.
This is inconvenient.
Wait a minute.
Hmm.
I can't.
I have to be level 20.
I'm trying to...
to grind it up for level 10 right now i'm trying to even get
to level 10.
wait there's a tv here oh my god wait there's a free tv i
didn't need to buy a tv they had a free tv just lying there
oh i have it the depressed monkey got you science fiction
that's old must have that but loud oh there you go Oh shit,
there's more return videos.
Oh, rewind, be kind, rewind.
Um, action.
Oh, please stop.
Chill.
Chill, I don't, there's so many things I have to do.
You think it's like the depressed universe?
That's like a multi...
It's like this depressed cinematic universe because we had
depressed monkey and depressed tentacle monster.
Oh.
Oh my god, there's only one.
There's only one left.
And here.
Youngko's last day.
Adult.
Action.
Science fiction.
Oh.
Oh here.
Oh, depressed money.
Why would you be depressed?
You have money.
It's just the universe we live in.
Alright, what's tomorrow?
Tomorrow.
It's New Tape Day!
New Tape Day!
Never escape.
We're almost there.
I can see it.
Journey XP to claim.
We're almost there, guys.
Hey, Jokey.
I'm sorry I'm late.
Here's a $5 late fee.
Thank you, the super chat, Fudge.
Thank you, thank you.
Sorry, it's $5 per hour.
We made a new roll.
It's joking.
I'm joking.
All right.
I should start buying more shows.
Or I'm going to keep me to leave it on the round.
Alright.
It's time to close.
Am I level 10 yet?
Am I here?
Oh, come on!
One more day.
I think.
Oh, maybe not.
It could be.
Oh, what's new?
What's new?
Watch the new film for today.
It's the haunting oh my gosh there's been so many all right
ten oh my god it's our grudge I mean it's our ring it's the
ring it's finally hit my cinematic universe it's finally
here not blockbuster there
you go so they'll have to buy it they'll be like whoa i feel
like maybe this usually like looks out right like you're
like oh the the static you're here right like whoa all right
i'm gonna do my daily returns
my action oh reserve
And...
Hello.
What is it?
The mood turn is slipped out.
Charge fee.
Why would you speak to the manager to tell me that you
fucking broke my movie?
Like...
I guess to apologize.
I guess he just wanted to apologize.
You know what?
Never mind.
You just wanted to apologize.
You know what?
I fuck with that.
Still gotta pay.
Yeah.
Yes, Wado?
Oh, Ninja.
Oh.
There you go.
That's right.
Instead of finding you, Wado, they're going to want to hide
from you after that.
All right, do you want to speak to me, too?
I'm a busy lady.
I'm a successful business owner.
That's right.
Yeah, damn right.
I don't need your service.
Good luck trying to find another video place.
I bought the rights.
It's a video renting.
Good luck finding another place.
It's all me now.
Romance.
There he is.
I found him.
Alright, wake up.
Oh.
Rewind.
Rewind again.
Guys, please, please rewind.
Be kind rewind.
Drama.
God, I think I need to buy another shelf.
That's it.
I'm inventing Netflix right now.
Good luck with that.
It'll never take off.
Watching movies online?
On dial-up?
You're fucking crazy.
Who's gonna want to do that?
Nobody's patient enough.
for that people need to make phone calls
what's next downloading video games on the internet oh here
oh hell hotel
ha what storage space good luck getting two gigabytes of
data of space for that good luck if you think your floppy
disk can store a video game all
right double merchant damn you're a call for that yeah good
luck having a floppy disk install video games on your pc
red action science fiction that's the ground Oh, X miss.
Oh, yeah.
I don't have too many adults.
No, I don't have enough.
Hi.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, that was a guy's voice.
Wait a minute.
I thought I heard a guy's voice on the phone.
Okay.
I definitely have too many videos.
I'm still doing the returns right now.
We won.
Oh my god.
I've been working from morning to night.
I'm still doing returns.
Oh my god.
Alright.
We finally finished returning everything.
Okay.
Poetry is dead.
Xmas.
I think I bought too much horror.
I think a shelf doesn't fit in no more.
Alright, let's see.
We might need another shelf.
I know it's a wild idea, but like I think it's time.
I think it's time to grab another shelf, guys.
Alright, this shelf.
I think it could be science fiction, honestly.
We can make it science fiction.
I'll put it here.
and then i'm gonna put this here and then this can be here
and then this would be oh i gotta throw this away it's here
and then this would be the science fiction
yeah all right who's calling me right now i'm a very busy
woman or our number
all right science fiction getting
there and then got her so far away from me and then we'll
put the science fiction here too oh wait drama.
Boop.
now.
Now no more floor videos.
I did it.
There you go.
Alright, that should be level 10, right?
That should be level 10 by now.
230.
That's fine.
A thousand movies.
I've done... I've rented a thousand movies out.
Oh my...
Wait.
I haven't made it though.
Wait, I didn't make it.
Wait a minute.
I'm still double nine.
No!
What do you mean I'm still level nine?
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'm gonna buy another one.
Then we'll finally have in preparation for drama week.
I think this would fit, right?
Okay, we're going to put this here.
Oh my god, please.
I'm working right now.
Alright, poetry is dead.
Ah, it's good to know poetry is dead.
It's still a classic.
Alright, and then we'll put this.
Yellow.
Drama, drama, drama.
Where do you go?
Where the fuck do I put this?
Oh, I could put this right here.
And then this.
Oh.
Perfect.
There you go.
Reminds you of the good old days.
Put the horror.
There you go.
And all the mixed section can still stay there.
so there we go we did it it's so organized now see poetry is
still it's not dead exactly
all right this is very addicting i will say oh my god there
he is oh sorry sorry sir sorry sir you get into a groove
wait where's my work okay I was gonna say
uh crystal thank you again for the super chat thank you
thank you yeah I got you I got you that Christmas movie it's
in my reserve now alright
I'm just clumsy charged V it's crazy the only the only like
not simulator thing, which I love, is that you don't have to
pay any bills.
Thank God.
Um, this is a religious, not blockbuster, so I don't have
to...
I am tax-exempt, apparently.
It's on religious grounds.
What religion is the tomato We don't find religion.
Oh.
Oh, hello.
Oh, let me give me a sec.
Let me put all of this away first, sir.
Drama, drama, drama, drama.
Drama.
Oh, romance.
Wait, what's...
Oh, shit.
Hello.
I have an Xmas movie that's on.
Let me check.
Xmas movie that's old.
I have an Xmas movie that's bad.
I have a lot of bad.
There is, well, not surprisingly.
Oh, there you go.
There is a lot of very bad Xmas movies.
Same with horror.
It reminds me of Family Video except it has colorful ones.
Now, I was thinking of Super Chat thinking, thank you.
adult movies can be romantic there can't there's plot in
some of them how else is there award shows for them there's
award shows for adult movies what if some people want to
watch for the plot
I actually ran out of space okay
I got you.
The shark in the bathtub?
Best plot I've ever seen in the...
It's not...
It's not a beach.
It's a bathtub.
Best writing ever.
You would think they were on a beach.
And then the plot twist was that they were in the bathtub
the entire time.
It was crazy.
The plot truly thickens.
I know, right?
I watched those movies for the plot.
No way.
This isn't a...
This isn't a beach.
It's a bathtub.
There's no shark here.
She was so convincing in that lifeguard role.
She sold herself into that role.
It made me really think that she was on the beach.
I'm gonna pick up the movie.
Here you go.
Romance.
Then...
There we go.
Is there anything else I can buy?
I feel like I...
I feel like it's just all like decorations and stuff like
that.
But it's like I don't really need any of that.
I just need this declarant's bin.
That's all I fucking need.
The word categories?
shooters like best acting, best writing, best like it's like
the Oscars, you know is it like the Oscars?
Best director, best light, best special effects.
Best costume design?
I remember on Twitter, someone was like, someone posted a
photo.
The costume design for the Overwatch aton film went crazy
like there's one way where it's like Reaper and it actually
looks like he's wearing like he's wearing like a natural
Reaper cosplay.
But you guys never seen that?
Like I will show you like it's literally just okay wait
Overwatch Reaper.
Wait what would it be called?
God.
Where the...
Why would it even be gone?
I'm just like, wait a minute.
I should have thought about this.
Like, I'm so tired.
I...
I should have thought about...
Oh, wait.
My snacks.
They're empty.
I was like, wait a minute, how do I even find this?
You're right, okay, it's parody.
There we go, there we go.
That's a good, I'm so tired.
Oh my god.
Don't search it up.
I saw a safe.
for work photo of it but but it clearly clearly there's a
lot of not safe for work stuff it's not called it's called
over snatch is it wait is it actually over snack
it was like well i don't even remember like i just remember
reaper being there i don't even remember who else was there
because i was like what the that's had actual reaper cosplay
Oh my god, it's Reaper and and and Widowmaker.
Wait, that costume goes hard though.
Wait a minute.
Bro, they got an act.
They got the Widowmaker gun and headgear.
Wait, what?
They actually made the Widowmaker like helmet and gun for
the fucking parody.
That's crazy.
Oh my god, I'm there.
Level 10!
Let's go, baby!
Today was supposed to be a short stream.
I got too into it.
I can't believe it's caught over, Snatch.
That's fucking...
That's wild.
Oh my god, it's here.
We got the bin.
That's all I wanted to do.
One day with the bin.
Yeah.
Alright, we gotta get rid of these.
They gotta get rid of these.
Get these out of here.
We've bought too many.
I'm sorry.
Poetry is dead.
You've been...
You've done so well, but I can't...
I don't have enough space for you.
You've done too well.
I'll keep a few.
copies no not my favorite film I just want someone else to
do this part it was a good run there's a Kotaku of course
there is the Kotaku review all right new it's still new
thank God I just want to see someone buying it I don't care
about anything else i just want to see them i just want to
see them i'm gonna watch i'm gonna stay here until someone
buys one
come on please give them a home give these poor videos a
home come on oh my god what do you want an old adult um um I
grabbed someone that returned it.
Give me a sec.
I'm going to check if anybody returned one.
Maybe?
Surely someone returned one.
Give me a sec.
I'm checking.
I'm...
Every film deserves a home.
I'm still checking, sir.
Give me a sec.
Oh, there you go.
I got you.
You're welcome.
Can someone please give them a home?
Oh.
Oh, I got baited.
Please.
They deserve love, too.
In the eyes of an angel.
no i i know because i know nobody took one because i left
three on top yeah i think i have i don't even know i do
hello is someone please please you're orphans oh wait
someone took one i turn no wait but i have to see someone
hold it i need to see someone take one it can't just be like
i have to see it happen with my own eyes
i have to witness it come on give them up home please please
if you don't i'll have to take it out to the trash you guys
don't want that right Shivering in the cold out there.
They deserve a nice home.
Place to stay.
To be rewinding and adopted.
Oh, what is it?
Okay, action movie.
Please.
I worked so hot.
Yeah!
We did it!
All right, shops close.
Shop.
all right shops close leave i'm ending the day leave i'm
closing the store whether you're in here or not oh my god
leave leave leave get out of here get out shops closed get
out
Oh, okay, I can't fuck you through that.
That's right.
It says 8 a.m.
to 12 a.m.
It's 12 a.m.
now.
Shop's closed.
Yay!
We did it!
Oh, my God.
And then the phone rings.
now it's time to file for bankruptcy mr.
broken bond thank you super chat thank you thank you oh yeah
it's fun i did not expect myself to play oh it's five hours
this is actually really addicting game is actually really
addicting i hope they add more content to it soon because it
looks like it max it maxes out at level 20 so i hope they
add more to it because it's actually it's actually really
roof i got really into the zone um i just wanted to call it
to see you guys are still open like ma'am not blockbuster
closed down yesterday
Give me a super chat.
Thank you.
I'm going.
Please stop throwing videos at me.
Give me a super chat.
Thank you.
I had a lot of fun.
If you guys like simulators, I think this is a...
I like this.
I think I like this more than the TCG simulator.
I mean, the opening the packs was pretty...
Was fun.
But I'm not like a pack.
I don't...
I'm not really a card person in terms of like...
I tried not to get into cards.
Because I don't want to get into the...
an addiction of opening packs um i don't i don't want i
don't want to get into that the addiction of that of buy of
trying to buy packs and opening them um but i i definitely i
definitely enjoy this game more i like this more i already
saved it game save um it's more than just selling tapes
Yeah, there was, like, another day, another dollar, I would
say.
Uh, yeah, I like, I definitely like this game more than the
other.
I think this is my favorite simulator so far.
Uh, I think this is the first, not the first, but, like,
the, out of all the simulator games I played, this game has
made me play the most hours on stream, for sure, definitely.
it a lot uh it's very nostalgic for people too um and you
get really into the zone of things um the floor plan the
floor pile has my favorite movie selections and in the end
and okay there's a lot of floor pile videos but that was
just me trying to find find certain videos um it's very cool
yeah it's definitely a very cozy fun game um for anyone that
likes simulators but yeah i'm gonna take a nap.
I'm a bit tired.
I'm gonna go take a nap.
And I definitely had a lot of fun playing this game and
streaming for you guys.
Always have fun streaming for you guys.
But anyway guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated, posh
check, get them around to get that blood flowing.
And you said for me, head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.